So, Leute, da bin ich mal wieder.
Eine Woche kein Stream.
Ich bin echt ein wenig beschäftigt gerade, nicht nur mit der Arbeit,
aber ich bin sinnloserweise wieder uralte Sachen am Spielen,
was ich vielleicht besser nicht machen sollte, weil das viel zu viel Zeit frisst
und ich lieber YouTube-Videos machen sollte, beziehungsweise streamen soll.
Aber so ist das halt, ne?
Manchmal hast du einfach Bock, irgendwelchen ollen Kram zu spielen,
der dir früher schon gefallen hat.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so eine Boomer-Angewohnheit.
Wenn man natürlich noch nicht so alt ist, dann kennt man das vielleicht nicht.
So, gucken, ob alles hier funzt.
Yo, bin ich laut? Warum?
Weil Teams wieder am Mikrofon rumgefuscht hat, wahrscheinlich.
Ah, Teams hat wieder am Mikrofon rumgefuscht.
Excellent, excellent.
Nein, nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich, äh, excellent.
Nee.
Ich kann den nicht hochladen.
Das ist ein MMO.
Das ist langweilig.
Ich mache aber ein Video drüber.
Ich wollte eigentlich gestern ein Video aufnehmen,
aber ich habe den ganzen Tag wieder sinnlos Kreisel-Crime gemacht.
Ach ja.
Lul.
W.
HD.
XD.
4K.
Ultra HD.
So.
Ja, Leute.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ist diese Woche irgendwas Spannendes?
Ich bin relativ früh.
Guckt mal hier.
9.14 Uhr.
9.34 Uhr.
Ich weiß nicht, manchmal kann ich...
Ich habe echt...
Ich habe ein großes Problem, Leute.
Ich sage euch das jetzt auch mal.
Also eine Sache, die mache ich seit Jahren und die ist eigentlich total three-head.
Ich fange einen Satz an und wenn ich nicht mehr weiß, wie er weitergeht, sage ich trotzdem irgendwas.
Ich habe auf die Uhr geguckt gerade und habe angefangen zu sagen, ah, es ist 9.
So, und dann habe ich nicht richtig gelesen.
Und habe einfach weiter geredet und er hat fast gesagt 9.34 Uhr.
Weil ich meine Augen, Boomer-Augen, ja, weil ich noch nicht richtig erkannt habe, was da eigentlich steht.
Also ich rede quasi schneller, als ich den restlichen Satz im Kopf vervollständigen kann.
Das ist ziemlich dumm, weil da kommen manchmal ziemlich bescheuerte Sachen raus, die keinen Sinn ergeben.
Das habt ihr wahrscheinlich im Stream auch schon gemerkt.
Ich müsste nochmal...
Es würde noch nicht...
Wenn ich einfach jetzt 200, 300 Millisekunden länger da drauf geguckt hätte, dann wüsste ich, was ich sagen will.
Und es hätte keiner gemerkt.
Aber nein, ich spreche das aus, bevor ich eigentlich weiß, was ich sagen will.
Oftmals fällt es nicht auf, weil das, was ich so predikte, was ich sagen will, ist meistens das, was ich auch sagen will.
Aber manchmal wäre es sinnvoll, einfach eine halbe Sekunde länger zu warten, bevor man was sagt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand kennt, aber das ist ziemlich dumm.
Kurz was trinken.
Das ist ziemlich bescheuert, ja.
Ja, mir macht das ja Spaß.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich mir eine Zeit nehmen muss und sage, hier, das quält mich voll oder so.
Ich habe richtig Bock, Sonntagmorgen zu streamen.
Vor allem, erstens, weil es Low-IQ, Low-Effort-Content ist.
Ich muss ja hier gar nichts machen, großartig sonntags.
Sonst muss ich mir immer, wenn wir irgendwas programmieren oder so, muss ich mir immer Gedanken machen, was machen wir dann.
Und sonst wie aber Sonntag, das kann ich einfach ein bisschen schwätzen.
Wir gucken uns ein paar Videos an, ich sage was zu aktuellen Themen oder so.
Ja, ja, ja, alles gut.
Mein Hals ist übrigens seit Wochen, die Woche ist kacke, war wieder besser.
Ich futter jetzt einfach morgens immer so 1-2 Bonbons und so und dann, das bringt tatsächlich was.
Das hier, Ricola, habe ich.
Ricola, Schweizer Kräuterzucker.
Wahrscheinlich cringet jetzt der Schweizer übelst zusammen, wenn ich das so ausspreche.
Ich habe mal kurz einen, einen Halsschien-Gachibas.
So.
Was gibt es Neues?
Ja, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch, Chat.
Tee, Honig, nee, ganz ehrlich, die Bonbons sind, sind, sind viel, viel leiser.
Ich habe mal eine Frage an die richtigen High-IQ-Leute im Chat und wir wissen ja, da jeder, äh, das ist schon wieder ein Satz.
Schon wieder ein Satz angefangen, ohne zu Ende zu denken.
Da jeder Prime-Sub den IQ erhöht, haben wir natürlich hier viele absolute Pfeifert High-IQ-Leute.
Hat jemand von euch schon mal die Postgres Fulltext Search verwendet?
Also, Fulltext Search.
Hat jemand von euch schon mal die Postgres Fulltext Suche mit Postgres gemacht?
Endlich, da hat da jemand einen Plan von.
Wenn nicht, müssen wir das, glaube ich, mal im Stream ausprobieren, weil, weil, ich habe mir, wir machen übrigens heute Mittag wahrscheinlich, mal gucken, wie es MMO-technisch aussieht, aber wahrscheinlich wollen wir heute Mittag ein bisschen Progress streamen.
Svelte, Svelte Skills verbessern, aber nicht mit dem To-Do, sondern wir bauen Autocomplete für was.
Und zwar, ich habe mir auf der Arbeit ein Thema...
Wie nennt man das?
Angelacht.
Ja, kann man das, kann man, kann man, kann man, denke ich, kann man, denke ich, so sehen.
Und zwar, ähm, habe ich meinem Chef vorgeschlagen, dass wir das machen könnten.
Ich schieße Hackerman-Thema und er hat gemeint, können wir machen.
Und zwar, ähm, für unseren Support, der muss ab und zu mal eintragen, von wann bis wann Systeme nicht verfügbar sind.
Ja, könnt ihr euch so vorstellen, die sitzen da vorne vor jeder Menge Monitoren.
Und da ploppt dann halt ab und zu mal ein System auf, wenn ein Check-Fail geschlagen ist.
Und da müssen die gucken, ist das System wirklich down oder ist es irgendwelche anderen Probleme.
So, und manchmal kommt es ja vor, dass Systeme runtergefahren werden, absichtlich.
Und dann müssen die eintragen, System ist down, keine Ahnung, heute, 23.01. von 19 bis 20 Uhr.
Und die aktuelle Lösung, die wir da gerade haben, ist ziemlich bare-bones.
Also, du musst Zeit in UTC eintragen.
In irgendeinem ISO-Timestamp ohne Autocomplete und solche Dinger.
Und da habe ich gesagt, ich könnte ja mal einfach so ein Mini-Formular-Webseite bauen.
Und wir machen das selbst und machen das halt besser.
Und bei der Gelegenheit habe ich mir gedacht, wenn wir das schon besser machen,
mal kurz die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen.
Bei der Gelegenheit, ihr kennt mich ja, ich belasse es dann nicht bei so einfachen Sachen.
Ich muss mir dann immer richtig, richtig, ja, es ist richtig Monat-Esther-System.
Egal.
Also, was heißt, ne, an sich ist das System eigentlich relativ gut.
Ähm, die Frontend-Sachen sind, sind aber Müll.
Und ihr, ihr kennt mich ja, wenn ich sowas baue, ich mache dann meistens immer übertriebene Sachen.
Und zwar, was ich mir überlegt habe, wäre es nicht cool, einfach, anstatt da einfach nur einen Textwell und einen Date-Time-Picker reinzumachen,
wäre es nicht cool, wenn man die Systeme, auf die sich das bezieht,
beziehungsweise auf die Alarme, auf die sich das bezieht,
doch, doch, ist es ja im Prinzip auch.
Aber so einfach ist es ja nicht.
Also, ich dachte mir, so wäre es nicht cool, dass man die, ähm, Alarme, auf die sich das bezieht, autocompliten kann.
Also, dass man eingeben kann, keine Ahnung, Hostname gleich Server-ABC oder sowas.
Oder dass man eingeben kann, Server-ABC, und der vervollständigt dir, ah, meinst du vielleicht Hostname gleich Server-ABC.
So.
Jetzt habe ich von unserem Prometheus mal.
Sämtliche Labels und sämtliche Values dazu abgefragt.
Das Problem ist nur, dass allein schon, jetzt haltet euch mal fest, jetzt haltet euch wirklich mal fest,
dass der allein der JSON-Export, also die rohen, die rohen, unzusammenhängen und nicht großartig geordneten Daten,
sind 650 MB Textfile.
So, das jetzt in irgendeiner geordneten Art und Weise in Memory zu speichern,
halte ich für schwierig.
Zumal man den Grammar noch schnell durchsuchen können muss.
Also stellt euch vor, ihr könnt euch einfach vorstellen, ich habe 650 MB Text,
und, ja, Stück für Stück einlesen.
Das Problem ist, ich will nicht nach 10 Sekunden was finden.
Ich möchte gerne Suchzeiten haben, so am besten von einer halben Sekunde, maximal eine Sekunde.
Am liebsten 50, 50, 60 Millisekunden.
Also ich will autocomplete haben.
Wenn dann einer anfängt zu tippen, zum Beispiel, Host oder so, dann soll er direkt autocompleten.
Oder wenn einer eingibt, Server 1, 2, oder wenn einer nur Server eingibt,
soll er schon 10 Vorschläge erhalten, Server 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, sonst was.
Das heißt, ich muss diese 650 MB JSON-Daten irgendwie so speichern, dass ich die möglichst schnell durchsuchen kann.
Die Sache ist die, ich habe es probiert, und man glaubt es gar nicht,
Blutforce ist erstaunlich schnell.
Ich habe einfach alles eingelesen in den Speicher, und daraus schon den Text konstruiert, den ich dann letztendlich ausgeben will.
Und ich durchsuche das.
Das geht verhältnismäßig schnell, aber das könnte schneller gehen.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, hat jemand Ahnung von der Postgres Fulltext Search?
Weil damit geht das bestimmt ähnlich schnell, sagen wir mal, aber mit viel, viel weniger RAM-Verbrauch.
Ich meine...
Meine Anwendung braucht 3,5 GB RAM, einfach nur weil ich das ganze Zeug in den Speicher hätte.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel, für nichts.
Wobei Arbeitsspeicher ist billig.
Ja, also falls jemand Ahnung hat, oder hat jemand irgendwie Ahnung von euch, von irgendeiner Suchmaschine,
was nicht gerade Elasticsearch ist, weil Elasticsearch ist einfach mega krasser Overkill dafür.
Nee.
Geht nicht.
Ich brauche alles, was da drinsteht, jedes...
Das einzige, was ich machen kann, ist, und das habe ich schon gemacht,
Values,
die länger als 60 Zeichen sind.
Die wird wahrscheinlich nie eine Auto-Compliten.
Die habe ich schon raus.
Grab.
Ja, mache ich ja im Prinzip gerade.
Im Prinzip mache ich sowas ähnliches wie Grab.
Nur von Hand.
Na?
Vorschleife drüber.
To lower.
Äh, String contains Suchbegriff.
Und am Ende noch sortieren, nach dem Label.
Nee, Elasticsearch ist zu krass für so ein kleines Ding.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Dann hätte ich eine Web-Anwendung.
Von...
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung.
300 Zeilen.
Aber ich bräuchte einen Elasticsearch.
Irgendwas Embeddedes wäre mir natürlich lieber.
Aber ich meine, Postgres kannst du immerhin einfach in einem Container starten.
Man könnte auch die Full-Text-Search von SQLite verwenden, aber die ist ziemlich schlecht
in Entity Framework Core integriert.
Cool, Vince.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Zinglore auch.
Danke für den Sub.
Der Schäger auch am Start.
Huge Subscriptions heute.
Egal.
Wir gucken uns das mal an.
Und vielleicht machen wir am Mittag Podcasts.
Dann sehen wir uns dann wieder.
Tschüss.
Und basteln ein bisschen z'Welt Autocomplete.
Weil so eine Autocomplete-Form ist an sich nicht schwierig, wenn es nicht Full-Text-Search
und...
Ähm...
Mal gucken.
Uts.js.
Das habe ich mir auch überlegt.
Das war das erste, was ich mir überlegt habe.
Aber nicht damit.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich die Node.js auf dem Server nehme.
Einen Suchindex generiere.
Und dann...
Und den Suchindex dann dann kleinschick und das rein kleinseitig mache.
Aber der Suchindex ist halt dann auch irgendwie...
Was weiß ich wie...
Wie fett...
Würde gerne alle meine Heizungen mit neuen Thermostaten ausstellen.
Kannst du was empfehlen?
Ja und nein.
Die Frage ist für welche Technologie.
Also ich hab an meinen Heizungen...
Am Anfang hatte ich die hier.
Guck mal.
Mal gucken ob das die waren.
Aber nicht kaufen.
Sag ich euch klar.
Äh Äh Moment.
Ja Na Na Na...
Nicht Thermostat.
Ich hatte mir am Anfang mal
einen Zwoa-Pack davon, ja, diese Dinger
waren das hier, davon gekauft.
Und Leute, ich sag euch, also so ähnlich
sehen die aus, das sind die bestimmt.
Die sind richtig scheiße.
Ich sag's wie es ist, richtig
scheiße. Kompletter Müll.
Laut wie Sau.
Also richtig, also wenn die
umstellen, wenn die, also nicht
kaufen, ne, sag ich so.
Wenn die rumstellen, macht's wirklich
Also hat die Katze schon fast immer erschreckt,
so laut war das.
Knopf nicht richtig zu bedienen.
Nicht richtig responsive.
Also absoluter Müll.
Und viel, viel zu teuer.
Ich schau mal kurz, was die für Bewertungen hier haben.
Was haben die hier für Bewertungen?
Können die überhaupt Bewertungen machen?
Also Müll. Vor allem für den Preis.
Kompletter Müll.
AliExpress, sich die zu kaufen.
Für
irgendwie
2,98
Das ist bestimmt Ali, das ist AliExpress
G-Bait.
Das ist AliExpress G-Bait. Ich wette mit euch,
in Wirklichkeit sind das nur die Batterien oder irgendwie
sowas.
Die kosten im Leben keine 2,98
23 Euro.
Na, nice.
Und was, und was, AliExpress,
was genau, was genau
kostet da jetzt 3 Euro?
Weder das, noch das, noch das, noch das,
noch das.
Nichts. Nichts kostet
2 Euro. 3 Euro.
Was ist das denn hier?
Ich kann schon verstehen, dass
Leute lieber bei Wish bestellen, als bei
AliExpress. Also die Noobs, die Noobs, ja.
Die Noobs bestellen lieber bei
Wish als bei AliExpress, weil
Wish ist Scam, sieht aber
auf den ersten Blick nicht aus wie nach Scam.
AliExpress sieht aus
wie Scam, ist aber
meistens kein Scam. Moin.
Übrigens, Leute,
keine Stockfotos.
Legit. Wird nur für dieses
Thermostat gefilmt.
So.
Und, aber, ich meine, da kostet
nichts 3 Euro davon.
Als, naja, Gucci
Baited. So, und das hier
ist halt auch letztendlich
nicht mal verfügbar. Also,
die Dinger sind Müll. Was ich habe,
ist, äh,
Fritz deckt
Thermostat.
3 Euro kostet
leeres Paket, ja. Die Dinger habe ich,
da würde ich aber warten. Manchmal
gibt es bei Amazon so ein
2er-Pack-Bundle, oder man muss mal bei
Geizhals gucken oder sowas.
So ein 2er-Pack-Bundle,
wo man die Dinger dann für irgendwie
umgerechnet 40 Euro ungefähr das Stück kriegt.
Das kann, die Dinger
kann ich tatsächlich empfehlen. Die funktionieren
von allem, was ich ausprobiert habe, bisher
am besten. Die Batterie
hält auch relativ
lange. Er hat mich
selbst, er hat mich selbst gewundert. Also, ich habe
das eingebaut. Vorletzte,
vorletztes Jahr,
vorletztes Jahr Oktober,
glaube ich, und das erste Thermostat ist
jetzt auf 50%.
Und das ist in dem Raum, wo im Winter
wirklich auch laufend
irgendwas geregelt wird, nämlich oben im Wohnzimmer.
Und das finde ich okay.
Also, ich sage mal, wenn die Batterie
2 Jahre hält, ist das in Ordnung.
Wenn es nach mir geht, sollte der Kran natürlich deutlich
länger halten, wie bei den Fenstersensoren, die ich habe,
aber das ist okay.
Nachteil bei denen ist,
und warum ich jetzt nicht einfach
sage, ja,
kauf dir das. Erstens, du brauchst eine Fritzbox,
dass die Dinger funktionieren.
Wobei, braucht man eine Fritzbox?
Moment.
Vielleicht gibt es, vielleicht gibt es
ja, irgendwas, wo das mit...
Na gut, du brauchst eine Deckbasisstation.
Da gibt es ja im Prinzip nur,
da gibt es ja im Prinzip nur sinnigerweise
die Fritzbox, die man dann auch ansteuern kann.
Ja, also, du brauchst eine Fritzbox,
das ist das Erste.
Und das Zweite ist, was vielleicht
einigen nicht gefällt, die haben
eine ziemlich lange Schaltzeit, unbekannt.
Die haben eine ziemlich lange
Schaltzeit. Also, die brauchen
teilweise bis zu 15 Minuten,
bis die schalten. Die rufen nämlich nur
alle 15 Minuten die Werte ab.
Also, ich meine, wenn man
am Gerät selber schaltet, kein Problem,
dann ist es direkt, aber wenn man
beispielsweise über die Heimautomatisierung setzt,
dann kann es bis zu 15 Minuten
dauern. Bin ich nicht schlimm,
weil ich schalte einfach morgens die Dinger
um 8 ein, und dann gehen die
halt auch ungefähr um 8 an.
Das reicht mir. Oder abends dann im
Wohnzimmer hochgefahren und sowas.
Das ist okay. Aber sagen wir mal, wenn
jetzt jemand
sagt, ah, ich gehe in 10 Minuten
ins Bad
und mache mich nackig,
und er drückt
dann auf Heizung hochfahren
und geht nach 10 Minuten ins Bad, und die Heizung hat
gerade ein ungünstiges Timing erwischt,
und fährt in 12 Minuten hoch,
ja, gut.
Dafür hat man eine relativ lange
Batterielaufzeit und ein an sich recht
zuverlässig funktionierendes
rundum eigentlich gut gemachtes
Gerät. Das war mir in dem Fall wichtiger.
So.
Also die kann ich empfehlen, aber halt nur mit den
Einschränkungen, die ich gerade gesagt habe.
Der Konbi-Stick ist übrigens
richtig nice. Ich habe
übrigens gelesen, dass
Sonoff jetzt auch einen ZigBee-Stick hat.
Sonoff hat jetzt auch einen ZigBee-Stick, glaube ich.
Aber, oder so?
Ja, keine Ahnung, ob das was taugt.
Aber ich habe auch einen Konbi 2, und das Ding ist richtig gut.
Ich verwende aber nicht ZH,
ich verwende ZigBee
2 MQTT, weil es mehr Geräte unterstützt
und meine besser unterstützt hat.
Ja. From Columbia. Nice.
Kannst du mir was
kleines 3D drucken und senden?
Nee.
Es gibt aber Services im Internet,
die machen das. Den kannst du das,
ähm, den Sketch schicken?
Nee, nee, nicht Sketch. Wie heißt das?
Das STL... Nee.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Das Model.
Kannst du den schicken? Oder machen die das für dich?
Es gibt 3D-Drucker-Services.
Ansonsten wisst ihr, was auch
ein super Ersatz ist für kleine
Plastikteile?
Heißkleber.
Mach einfach Heißkleber
dran. Wenn die Tastatur
wackelt, mach einfach Heißkleber
auf der einen Seite dran.
Und im Zweifelsfall
kürze es halt ein bisschen mit einer Schere, bis es passt.
Heißkleber ist auch ziemlich stabil.
Heißkleber ist es eh
unglaublich, was man mit Heißkleber alles fixen kann.
Unnötig. Heizung auf volle Pulle,
wenn es zu warm wird, mach Fenster auf.
Ja, funktioniert bei mir nicht.
Weil bei mir sowohl das Thermostat als auch der Fenstersensor
erkennt, dass das Fenster geöffnet wird
und macht die Heizung aus.
Leider, leider
ist meine Heimautomatisierung
zu 5-Head
für diesen Vorschlag.
Im Prinzip ist es so.
Also mit Heißkleber kann man viel machen.
Ich bin selbst ja
erst vor ein paar Jahren so auf Heißkleber gekommen.
Ich hab mir immer gedacht, wofür brauchen die Leute
Heißkleber? Nimmst du ein bisschen Sekundenkleber?
Nimmst du ein bisschen Uhu?
Irgendwie sowas.
Aber seit ich Heißkleber hab, wird alles, was zu kleben ist
und das funktioniert, wird geheiß-heißklebert.
Oh mein Gott, danke für den Sub.
Wenn du noch...
Oh, jetzt kommen die High-IQ-Fragen.
Wenn du noch einmal die Entscheidung hättest,
würdest du dich beruflich umentscheiden?
Ja, würde ich.
Aber ich würde es wieder genauso machen
wie vorher.
Also wie...
wie ich es jetzt gemacht habe.
Also wie ich das meine ist,
vielleicht
hab ich das noch nicht oft genug erzählt, aber
ich habe hier allen Ernstes
und das kann man sich bei mir
gar nicht vorstellen und ich mir jetzt genauso wenig,
dass ich das tatsächlich mal in Erwägung gezogen habe.
Ich habe tatsächlich
versucht, oder was heißt versucht?
Ich habe. Ich hab's ja nicht nur versucht.
Ich hab das ja wirklich
gemacht.
Ich hab was Kaufmännisches gelernt.
Kann man sich bei mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich hab Bürokaufmann gelernt.
Weil in einem
Leben
vor
der IT.
Und
das ist so scheiße.
Ich hab so keinen Bock auf diesen Kram.
Und ich wollte schon immer
eigentlich was mit Computer machen.
Um es mal so abstrakt zu sagen.
Ihr kennt ja die Story, wo ich damals beim
Arbeitsamt gewesen bin,
wo die mir erzählt haben, ich soll Schreiner werden,
was mit Holz machen, wo ich gesagt hab,
nee, nee, will ich nicht.
Und ja, also das würde ich immer wieder
machen.
Also.
Kaufmännische Sachen, Bürokaufmann, das ist überhaupt nicht meins gewesen.
Ich hab ja die Ausbildung relativ spät gemacht.
Ich mein, guck mal, 2007.
Und ich bin 1984 geboren.
Wie alt, wie alt war ich da?
Kopf, Kopf, quick, waffs, kein, heute nicht, 23.
Naja, geht doch eigentlich.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Aber es war damals auf jeden Fall relativ spät.
Nein, 20.
2007 begonnen.
2007 hab ich angefangen.
Also fertig war ich 2010.
Mit 26.
Ja.
Bonbon.
Runterschlucken.
Mit 26.
Naja, also die Ausbildung war nicht mit einem Haufen 16-Jähriger.
Die waren auch alle, sag man mal,
irgendwie so 18, 19, 20.
Aber ich war, ich war nicht,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich,
also ich war auf jeden Fall, wenn nicht der Älteste,
einer der zwei, drei Ältesten, auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Und, wie gesagt, ich hatte absolut keinen Bock auf Kaufmannskram.
Das ist auch überhaupt nicht meins.
Ich hab auch immer gekotzt, wenn man, wenn wir in der Ausbildung,
in der Berufsschule, kaufmännische Sachen gemacht haben.
Weil da musste ich mir manche Sachen, gut, ich hatte Glück,
ich hatte von vielem schon ein bisschen Ahnung.
Aber, das kann nicht sein, hab ich so abgefuckt.
Ja.
Das ist überhaupt nicht meins.
Es ist auch heute, glaube ich, ein bisschen anders.
Es war, also, sagen wir mal so, meine Generation,
vielleicht auch ein bisschen davor, da bist du eigentlich,
hast du mit 16 angefangen, irgendwie deine Ausbildung zu machen,
hast du es dann dein restliches Leben gemacht.
So.
Das, der Sache habe ich damals schon skeptisch gegenüber gestanden,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, ne, das war bestimmt nicht mein letztes Mal
mein ganzes Leben lang.
So.
Zumindest, das war auch damals so,
dass mir, dass mir meine Eltern, die sind mir halt alle ein bisschen
auf den Keks gegangen, ich soll jetzt irgendwas machen,
weil ich habe euch ja schon erzählt, ich habe quasi nach der Schule erst mal,
keine Ahnung, zwei Jahre oder so daheim gehockt, MMOs gespielt,
Kreisel grindet und nichts gemacht.
Also quasi heutzutage würde man sagen, Harzer Lifestyle.
Aber, die haben mir da natürlich ziemlich, die haben mich natürlich
ziemlich genervt damals, dass ich irgendwas mache.
Naja, egal.
Zumindest,
habe ich dann irgendwann gedacht, ne, den Scheiß kannst du nicht mehr geben.
Ja, klar, warum nicht?
Ich denke, in der heutigen Zeit ist es auch überhaupt kein Problem mehr.
Wir haben einen bei uns auf der Arbeit, der ist, glaube ich, fast 50 mittlerweile.
Und er hat seine Ausbildung auch gemacht, fast zum gleichen Zeitpunkt wie ich.
Das heißt, er war ungefähr so alt wie ich jetzt, als er seine Ausbildung gemacht hat.
Nochmal.
Also, das ist in der heutigen Zeit schon so.
Also, das ist in der heutigen Zeit schon mehr drinne.
Und ich sehe auch überhaupt kein Problem drinne, wenn man sich, wenn man älter ist und sich denkt,
ey, ich habe da keinen Bock mehr drauf oder aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen, kann ja auch sein.
Es gibt nichts mehr an dem ursprünglichen Beruf oder ich will mal doch was anderes.
Kann ja alles sein, ja.
Sehe ich überhaupt keine Probleme drin.
Und gerade Leute, die in die IT gehen, sind ja oftmals welche, die sich da schon lange dafür interessieren.
Wie gesagt, ich habe Programmieren gelernt 2001.
Habe ich angefangen.
Ich habe sogar noch ein bisschen früher angefangen mit Python, was weiß ich, 2, 1, irgendwas oder so.
Uralt.
Da weiß ich noch, da war ich damals noch mit meiner Mutter und ihrem Kerl im Urlaub.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Das muss ja irgendwie, keine Ahnung, muss ich irgendwie 17 oder so gewesen sein.
Da hatte ich ein Python-Buch dabei.
So richtig Nerd-Style, ja.
Hatte ich ein Python-Buch dabei.
Habt ihr es da gelesen?
Offline, muss man sich vorstellen.
Ich habe Offline-Programmieren gelernt.
Naja, zumindest, Kobol, ja.
Zumindest, ähm, hat mich das damals ja alle schon interessiert.
Aber zu dieser Zeit war es halt so, es gab auch nicht so viele IT-Ausbildungsplätze.
Ich habe ja damals ein paar Bewerbungen geschrieben, aber das hat alles nicht funktioniert.
Und ich habe mich halt belabern lassen, sowohl von meinen Eltern und halt auch Arbeitsamt und sonst was.
Und dass das, dass das halt keine so gute Idee ist und was auch immer.
Richtig dumm eigentlich.
Und ich war halt faul as fuck.
Hätte ich einfach ein paar mehr Bewerbungen geschrieben und mir ein bisschen mehr Mühe gegeben,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich damals schon irgendeine Ausbildung in den Bereich gekriegt.
Wobei man sagen muss, damals gab es glaube ich noch gar keinen Fachinformatiker.
Ich glaube, Fachinformatiker gibt es erst seit 2005 oder so.
Naja.
Ja.
Und viele Leute, die jetzt sich entscheiden, in die IT zu gehen, obwohl sie vorher was anderes gemacht haben,
sind ja oftmals auch Leute, die sich dafür schon lange interessieren.
Weil von irgendwo muss es kommen und auch schon Vorkenntnisse in dem Bereich haben.
Gibt es ja immer wieder hier im Stream so die Frage, sagt jemand, Max, wie lerne ich Programmieren oder sonst was.
Also ich hatte letztens einen im Stream, der meinte, er ist in irgendeinem Bootcamp gewesen oder so und hat das da gelernt.
Konnte ich überhaupt nichts zu sagen, keine Ahnung von.
Also ich kenne eigentlich ausschließlich Leute, die sich das selbst beigebracht haben.
Auch die, die studiert haben.
Die sagen alle, ja.
Ja, da lernst du das.
Da lernst du, was weiß ich, LinkedLists theoretisch, wobei LinkedLists eines der einfachsten Dinger ist in der Theorie, die es so gibt.
Aber da gibt es natürlich ein deutlich komplizierteres.
Aber so wirklich lernen tust du es nur, indem du es selbst machst und vor allem, indem du liest, was andere schon fabriziert haben und das versuchst nachzuvollziehen.
Also Code lesen und Sachen selbst programmieren und Try und Error ist eigentlich das, wie man es lernt.
So.
Excellent.
Hätten wir das?
Ja.
Warum nicht?
Ich meine, wenn man auf Java, also wenn es denn unbedingt Java sein muss, warum nicht, ja?
Ohne, ich hatte kein Notebook oder sonst was dabei.
Ich hatte ein Python-Buch dabei, offline, nur ein Buch.
Das war, ich habe das heute noch, ich weiß aber nicht, wo es ist und wie es heißt.
Das war ein Python-Lernen oder Python, ob ihr, das war ein graues Buch.
So ein komplett graues Buch.
Das könnte auch, das könnte auch.
Leute.
Glaubt, das ist es.
Das war aber damals noch grau.
Aber der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ich habe das gar nicht compiled.
Ich habe das einfach gelesen und versteht.
Mai 2005.
Ich glaube aber, das war das.
Das ist aber ein bisschen spät.
Guck mal, hier sind, hier sind Briefies von 2004.
Kann das sein, dass es das einfach die letzte Ausgabe davon ist?
Mit CD, ja, ja.
Das müsste so 2001 oder so wahrscheinlich rum gewesen sein oder 2002.
Egal.
Ich glaube, das war das.
Gut, ja, Turbo Pascal, ich meine, man kann damit immer noch was machen.
Aber so wirklich am Puls der Zeit würde ich nicht sagen.
Eher nicht.
Aber du kannst damit sicherlich noch was machen.
Es gibt sogar, habe ich letztens gesehen, wie heißt das, Lazarus oder so?
Es gibt irgendwie so eine moderne Pascal Delphi Implementierung, sogar mit GUI und sowas.
Ich glaube, Lazarus hieß das, wo ich mich auch gefragt habe.
Kennt das jemand?
Wo ich mich auch gefragt habe.
Alter, es gibt Leute, die 2022 immer noch neue Delphi und Pascal Projekte anfangen.
Ich habe am, ich habe morgen, ach morgen, ich vergesse immer, morgen ist ja, morgen ist ja Montag schon wieder.
Gut, dass ich morgen frei habe.
Und ihr nicht.
So.
Ich habe am Morgen einen Vorstellungsbericht für eine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker.
Da ist das Datenverarbeitung.
Lazarus ist kacke.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Habe ich aber nicht, habe ich nicht ausprobiert, habe ich nur letztens gelesen.
Chat.
Und Chat, Chat, soll ich euch, soll ich euch nochmal, nochmal mehr dran erinnern?
Okay, ich lasse es jetzt, ich lasse es jetzt sein.
Ich lasse es jetzt sein.
So, gleich mal 50 Leute abgeschaltet, instant.
So, ja, Fachinformatiker Datenverarbeitung ist das, glaube ich.
Ja, wusste ich gar nicht, dass das Leute ausschreiben.
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt, die gibt es ja seit zwei Jahren oder so bei der IHK.
Digitale Vernetzung, nicht Datenverarbeitung.
Wie heißt denn das andere?
Es gibt ja noch so ein Big Data Ding.
Ich dachte, das wäre das.
Moment.
Neue Fachinformatik.
Es gibt doch noch so, ich dachte, das ist dieses Big Data Ding.
Also, zeigt mal her.
Daten und Prozessanalyse habe ich gemeint.
Nicht Datenverarbeitung.
Digitale Vernetzung.
Das war früher alles Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Warum?
Egal, man muss das nicht verstehen.
Aber, nice.
Ja, ich hoffe, es klappt bei dir.
Der Mechaniker.
Den richtigen Namen dafür hast du ja schon mal.
Ich habe auch mit 16, 17 eine IT-Ausbildung gemacht.
18 angefangen.
Damit zu arbeiten und mit 26 waren schon massiv Berufserfahrung.
Bei uns fangen immer wieder Leute an, Mitte 30.
Ja, bei uns auch.
Ja, ja, ja, bei uns auch.
Und man muss da sagen.
Man muss dazu sagen, auch ein Studium in dem Bereich garantiert dir nicht,
dass du irgendwie eine super Position kriegst.
Wir haben beispielsweise bei uns im Support, ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal Support,
also dort, wo Leute anrufen und sagen, oh, unser System geht nicht.
Und dann wird ein Ticket aufgemacht und sonst was.
Da haben wir einige, die Informatik studiert haben, aber die vielleicht den Binary Tree
inverten können.
Aber von der Praxis nicht so viel Ahnung.
Die Ahnung haben wir andere.
Also es ist interessant, ja.
Also Info, das heißt nicht, dass sie blöd sind oder so.
Muss ich jetzt an der Stelle auch nochmal sagen.
Aber da sieht man, dass ein Informatikstudium alleine jetzt auch nicht Garant dafür ist,
dass man irgendwie super krassen Job kriegt.
Wichtig ist, dass man was kann und vor allem halt auch dann was, was gesucht wird.
Aber wichtig ist, dass man was kann, dass man wirklich gut kann.
Unsere Firma hat sowas wie Bootcamp für IT und Co.
Proger, Scrum.
Ah, Scrum Master, Alter.
Da kommen alles Mögliche rein.
Auch Fischer und Physiker, um in der IT zu arbeiten.
Das Ding hilft auch.
Fischer.
Warum nicht?
Hat Unrate dich jetzt eigentlich überzeugt?
Ich habe Unrate nicht ausprobiert.
Wir wollten das im Stream mal ausprobieren.
Haben wir noch nicht gemacht, weil ich die letzten zwei Wochen fast nicht gestreamt habe.
Guckt euch mal an.
Ich meine, das ist ja armselig.
Guckt euch mal meine Stream-History an.
Schaut nochmal, das ist richtig mies.
Max, klar behalten.
Hier.
Das ist richtig.
Richtig mies.
Aufwachen-Stream.
Sieben Tage davor aufwachen-Stream.
So.
Und davor war Dezember.
Da haben wir quasi jeden Tag gestreamt.
Fast jeden Tag.
Tja.
Verstehe auch nicht, warum sich Eltern bekannt sind so in der Berufung.
Naja.
Gut, warum sich die Eltern so einmischen, kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Die Eltern wollen halt, dass ihr Kind was macht.
Und nicht daheim sitzt.
Die wollen ja nicht, dass das Kind hart so wird.
Kann man sich ja auch irgendwie vorstellen.
Die Eltern sind halt immer besorgt drum.
Du warst nicht faul, sondern arbeitseffektiv.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Ich bin heute immer noch faul as fuck.
Ich muss jetzt aufpassen, ab und zu guckt mein Chef auch meinen Stream, ja.
Aber ich glaube, dass es nichts Schlimmes war, wenn man sagt, ich bin faul as fuck.
Aber dafür sind die Sachen, behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal, ja.
So aus meiner Sicht zumindest.
Dafür sind die Sachen, die ich mache, insoweit durchdacht und komplett, dass ich mich nie wieder damit beschäftigen muss.
Also faule Leute sind gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Die Lösungen, die faule Leute erarbeiten, sind oftmals durchdacht.
Kennt ihr dieses, kennt ihr dieses Chart?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das richtig hinkriege.
Ich versuche das mal kurz zu malen.
Das habe ich in einem Vortrag auf YouTube gesehen.
Also kann sein, dass ich das jetzt nicht richtig hinbekomme.
Wie macht man die Size von dem Stift?
So.
Also.
So eine Tabelle.
So.
Ähm.
So, du hast Leute, die sind faul.
Und du hast, also du hast zwei Kategorien.
Faul und fleißig.
Und du hast, ähm, kein Plan und Ahnung.
Versus Ahnung.
So.
Also das hier ist.
Wie, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also das hier ist, das hier ist Skill.
Skill.
Ähm.
Ich bin nicht in der Lage, das richtig, richtig zu malen, Alter.
Und das hier ist, äh, nee.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn, was ich da mache.
Ich kann, ich bin, ich bin zu blöd, das aus dem, aus dem Talk wiederzugeben.
Ähm.
Zumindest war das eine, zumindest war das eine, so Entscheidungshilfe für Führungskräfte.
Welche Leute sie nehmen würde.
Also, also.
Ich schreibe das jetzt einfach mal rein.
Hier.
Ähm.
Motti.
Motiviert.
Und, ähm.
Planlos.
Gibt's die Kombination.
So.
Dann hast du die Kombination.
Motiviert.
Und, ähm.
Ja, wie nennen wir das andere?
Ahnung, oder, oder, oder.
Ja.
Wie, wie nennt man das?
Was ist das Gegenteil von planlos?
Kompetent.
Dann hast du Foul.
Und du hast Foul.
Kompetent.
Planlos.
So.
Das war ein Talk auf YouTube.
Das denke ich nicht, das habe ich für dich auch.
Das war, das war ein Talk auf YouTube, den ich gesehen habe.
So.
Und er meinte so, also so als Empfehlung für, für Führungskräfte.
Ähm.
Wo fangen wir, wo fangen wir, wo fangen wir denn an?
Foul und kompetent, meinte er, ist die optimale Führungskraft, weil kann Leute gut delegieren.
Ähm.
Und ist an Funkt, ist halt.
Und ist an qualitativ hochwertigen Lösungen interessiert.
Optimale Führungskraft.
Foul und kompetent.
Ähm.
Foul und planlos ist auch nicht schlimm.
Foul und planlos kannst du auch manche Leute gebrauchen.
Ähm.
Dann gibt es noch die Kombination motiviert und kompetent.
Und da meinte er so, das sind so quasi die Dinger, die jetzt so die, so die, so die Premium-Mitarbeiter, die man auf jeden Fall behalten muss.
Und dann gibt's was.
Das liegt relativ nah beieinander mit dem hier.
Und ist auf den ersten Blick nicht richtig zu erkennen.
Ähm.
Es gibt die Leute, die sind motiviert und planlos.
Und die sind gefährlich, weil, also wie gesagt, laut diesem YouTube-Talk, motiviert und planlos in Kombination ist nicht etwa, dass man eine Tugend hat, aber planlos ist.
Das ist das Schlechteste, was es gibt, weil die machen laufend was, aber machen es die ganze Zeit kaputt.
Die haben halt keine Ahnung und sind motiviert.
Das heißt.
Die sind permanent am keine Ahnung machen.
Das ist schlecht.
Er hat gesagt, man kann alles gebrauchen.
Das kann man gebrauchen.
Nur das hier, motiviert und planlos, kann man überhaupt nicht gebrauchen.
Und ich finde, klingt irgendwie logisch.
Genau.
Und ich würde mich, wenn ich jetzt mal so, insofern selbst loben darf.
Ich denke, nach so vielen Streams, wo wir Sachen programmiert haben, Linux-Sachen gemacht haben.
Ich würde sagen, ich habe nicht komplett keine Ahnung von diesem Bereich.
Ja, also ich würde mich mal in diesem Bereich hier einordnen.
Ich bin definitiv nicht hier.
Ich würde mich hier einordnen.
Ich habe eigentlich halbwegs Ahnung von dem, was ich mache, aber ich bin faul.
Es fuckt motiviert und planlos gleich Azubi, wenn es ein guter, wenn es jemand ist, der sich gut.
Deswegen dürfen Azubis ja auch nichts allein machen.
Aber wenn es jemand ist, der wirklich motiviert ist und was lernen will, dann ist er auch relativ schnell hier.
Die Sache ist nur die.
Es ist durchaus möglich.
Das stimmt, da habe ich ganz vergessen.
Das kam in dem Talk auch noch.
Der hat gemeint, es kann durchaus sein, dass Leute wechseln, also dass man viele Leute hier hat, die immer weiter auch in dieses Lager wechseln durch schlechtes Management.
Die sind dann immer noch kompetent.
Aber die haben keinen Bock mehr, weil es ihnen auf den Sack geht.
Zumindest das war der Talk.
Der fand ich. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Titel hieß.
Ich glaube, ich werde den jetzt auch nicht mehr finden.
Aber ich habe so einen Talk mal geschaut auf YouTube und ich fand das eigentlich ganz gut, die Kategorisierung.
Und ich glaube, die meisten kann man da wirklich einordnen.
Kenne ich.
Kennt, glaube ich, jeder, ja.
Genau, deswegen würde ich mich tatsächlich da einordnen.
Seit 1997 gibt es Physik, krass.
Aha, aha.
Ich weiß noch, wie die vom Arbeitsamt damals in der Schule eine Art...
Jaja, haben sie bei mir auch gemacht.
Ähm, okay, das haben sie bei uns nicht gemacht, aber die haben das total belacht.
Ja.
Es ist so lächerlich gewesen, so im Nachhinein, wie planlos eigentlich die Leute beim Arbeitsamt sind.
Ich war ja damals auch beim Arbeitsamt.
Moin, Rinax.
Ich war ja damals auch beim Arbeitsamt und der Super-Me-Advice ist auch da.
Ich war ja damals auch beim Arbeitsamt und da musste ich solche, oder das sollte ich, so Zettel ausfüllen.
Und da waren dann so Sachen drin wie, basteln sie gerne und sowas in der Richtung.
Und das habe ich alles eingekreuzt.
Ja, ich bastel gerne halt, ich baue gerne Computer zusammen und sonst was.
Und am Ende kommt raus, ich soll was mit Holz machen.
Das habe ich jetzt schon 85.000 Mal erzählt, ich weiß.
Und dann hat er mir das Ergebnis gezeigt und hat gesagt, ich will aber nichts mit Holz machen.
Ich habe das ausgefüllt, weil ich gerne mit Hardware bastel.
Und da sind wir die Fragen durchgegangen und da habe ich ihm zu jeder Frage gesagt,
ja, ja, mir geht es hier nicht um irgendwelche handwerkliche Bastelsachen.
Ich will das machen, weil ich zum Beispiel Netzwerke aufbaue und so.
Das verstehe ich darunter.
Und da hat der Typ immer gesagt, ja, da sieht man alles auf Computer ausgelegt.
So richtig überheblicher Kackspast gewesen.
Ja, ja, alles auf Computer ausgelegt.
Alter, ihr Kack-Schnarch-Nasen, Alter, das war 2000, was weiß ich, eins oder so, keine Ahnung.
Da wurden die Weichen für die Zukunft gestellt.
Und wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr, was passiert ist?
Durch so Kackspasten wie den sind wir jetzt, also nicht durch ihn jetzt alleine, ja, aber ihr wisst, wie ich das meine.
Durch Kackspasten wie ihn sind wir da, wo wir heute sind.
Beschissen, Internet.
Ausbau.
Leute, die immer noch lieber die Angst haben, bei Amazon einzukaufen.
Technikfeindliche Leute.
Große Unternehmen, die kein Homeoffice wollen.
Wegen solchen Leuten sind wir da.
Weil die 2001, da wo die Weichen mitgestellt wurden, gesagt haben, ha, ha, was mit Computer, ha, ha, jo, lul.
Ja, ist so.
Das haben die in Japan und Korea komplett anders gemacht.
Schlimm, schlimm.
Richtig, genau.
Was spricht?
Gegen Java?
Oracle.
Nee, eigentlich spricht nix gegen Java.
Java ist durchaus in Ordnung, aber auch über, ich mach mich halt über Java ganz gerne lustig.
Ich kann dazu nix sagen.
Ich hab davon keine Ahnung.
Wirklich nicht.
Ich, ich, also ich hab mir das durchgelesen, aber ich habe nicht gecheckt, wofür es diese drei neuen Ausbildungen jetzt eigentlich genau, genau braucht.
Muss mal kurz meinen Pulli zumachen hier.
Oder meine Jacke zumachen, sonst kratzt das Mikrofon so sehr am...
Am Reißverschluss und dann gibt es wieder einen Clip, Max furzt im Stream.
Es gab, letztens hat einer einen Clip gemacht, da bin ich hier mit dem, mit dem Reißverschluss gegen das Mikrofon gekommen, da gab es dann gleich einen Clip, Max furzt im Stream.
Ähm, im Stream.
Hä?
Bitkom, Bitkom, Bitkom sind doch immer die, die sagen Fachkräftemangel.
Ja, richtig, so sieht's aus.
Wie gesagt, das hab ich zwar im Video gesagt, aber das ist nicht von mir.
Es ist von irgendeinem Philosoph, fragt mich nicht, es ist nicht von Schiller, äh, wenn man das Zitat sucht, steht oftmals, dass es von Schiller ist, ist es aber nicht, es ist von irgendjemand anderem.
Ich weiß nicht von wem, also das ist nicht, dass ich mir das jetzt irgendwie für das Video ausgedacht hätte.
Können, wollen, Matrix, aha.
Was für alles, ich wüsste, wir, ich sag doch, Prime Subs lohnen sich, wir haben so viele High IQ Leute im Chat, die sowas wissen.
So, aber wir gucken uns jetzt mal Videos an, wird echt Zeit.
Ne, ich hab das noch auf Papier gemacht, war noch kein Terminal.
Ich bin aber letztens mal wieder bei uns in Hanau am Arbeitsamt vorbeigelaufen und es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich mich da gefragt habe, also an diesem Jobberatungscenter, es gibt zwei Sachen, was ich mich da gefragt habe.
Erstens, warum am Bahnhof und Umgebung eigentlich in so gut wie jeder Stadt sozialer Brennpunkt ist, hat da irgendjemand, gibt es da für irgendeine Erklärung, warum ist immer Ghetto um die Bahnhöfe rum?
Drittens, warum am Bahnhof und Umgebung eigentlich in so gut wie jeder Stadt sozialer Brennpunkt ist, hat da irgendjemand, gibt es da für irgendeine Erklärung, warum ist immer Ghetto um die Bahnhöfe rum?
Was, was, was hat es mit Hauptbahnhöfen so an sich, dass da immer so sozialer, sozialer Brennpunkt ist, ja, keine Ahnung.
Bin da vorbeigelaufen, Hauptbahnhof außenrum und hab mir gedacht, Alter, was hier für Leute rumlaufen, das ist ja fast schon wie in Frankfurt.
Ja, und, ähm, genau, wie ich eigentlich draufgekommen bin, ich bin dann auch an diesen, diesen Beratungsräumen vorbeigelaufen vom Arbeitsamt, da kannst du von außen reingucken und der Scheiß da drin sah noch aus wie vor 15 Jahren.
von den Rechnern, von dem
ganzen Gebäude. Das sieht einfach
aus wie technologischer Stand letztes
Jahrtausend. Ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
Sind Hetzner-Videos schon alle vorbereitet,
wo es Kupernetes gehen sollte? Ne, ich hab noch
nix weitergemacht. Ich hab mit
Hetzner auch noch nix abgemacht für dieses Jahr.
Ich müsste das an meine Managers
weiterleiten.
Es ist tatsächlich
wirklich praktisch, wenn man so jemand hat,
der das macht. Und er macht das auch echt
gut.
Ähm.
Ich muss grad mal in meine Mails gucken.
Ich hab bestimmt wieder die Hälfte vergessen.
Ich frag mich ja, wann ich die ersten
Anfragen kriege, für irgendwelchen
NFT-Scheiß zu promoten.
Kann immer lange dauern.
Wenn sogar Ozzy Osbourne
ein NFT hat, das sagt schon alles.
NFT
of Darkness, dann keine Ahnung, wie der
Kram von ihm heißt, aber
dann ist vorbei. Gut, der Typ
hat es ja auch nicht selbst gemacht, sondern
wahrscheinlich hat ihm irgendein Berater gesagt, mach mal
ein NFT.
Ja, ja, das macht er. Also nicht, ich rede nicht
von meinem Netzwerk. Mein Netzwerk macht nix.
Da muss ich eh mal raus, weil die
nehmen sich immer noch einen Cut von meinen YouTube-Einnahmen,
ohne was zu machen dafür.
Aber, ähm,
der Wettress macht das echt gut.
Er ist leider
zu viel am Managen,
dass er, glaube ich, so viel Zeug zu tun hat,
dass er gar nicht mal durchblickt so richtig.
Oder dem seinen Tag
bräuchte, glaube ich, 38 Stunden.
So. Also, was gucken wir uns denn für Videos?
An. Aboffers.
H0. Lustig.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
KW. Oh, guck mal, ich krieg mein eigenes Video
empfohlen. Direkt mal draufklicken.
Excellent.
51.000 Views, Pog.
Da hat jemand 1 zu 1
die Nachrichten vorgelesen. Stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Dann zeig mir mal, was ich angeblich
vorgelesen hab.
Stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Was machen die?
Übrigens, habt ihr schon
das neuste, ähm,
fast schon Poggers YouTube
Feature gesehen? Man kann jetzt hier drüber
hovern und dann geht ein Player
auf. Dann kann man dem Lost zugucken,
wie er sich über Battlefield auslässt.
Da muss man nicht mal hier runter ein extra
Tap machen. Wir können uns das
tatsächlich angucken gleich.
Gucken, was er von sich gibt.
So.
Ach ja, und eine Sache, die mir,
die ich vorher empfohlen bekommen habe, wo ich
euch jetzt mal zeigen muss, was mich
wirklich nervt an YouTube Thumbnails.
Ist das hier.
Why I stop, wir gucken uns
das Video nicht an. Why I stop
playing Battlefield 42. So, Leute.
So sicher wie das Armen
in der Kirche, darauf, wo
diese Pfeile zeigen, hat nichts
damit zu tun, warum er aufhört.
Und darauf, wo dieser Pfeil
zeigt, hat auch nichts damit zu tun.
Der ganze Screenshot, das ganze Ding
hat nichts damit zu tun,
weil er aufhört. Nichts.
Ich hasse solche Thumbnails.
Ich hasse das. Das geht mir so auf den Sack.
So, jetzt muss ich
jetzt einfach mal loswerden.
Next. Kennt das noch jemand?
Ja.
Warum rot und
weiß? Wahrscheinlich, weil
das dann mehr zum Klicken
verleiht. Keine Ahnung.
Wobei, ich habe auch letztens ein Thumbnail
mit Pfeilen gemacht, muss ich ja sagen.
Allerdings finde ich, hat das
hier.
Log4j Sicherheitslücke.
Aber zumindest hat das irgendwie
einen Bezug, weil das bin ja ich.
Oh. Leute, ich muss sagen,
jetzt mal ehrlich,
im Vergleich zu früher,
sind meine Thumbnails mittlerweile doch
für selbst gemacht echt
in Ordnung, oder?
Ich habe lange gebraucht, für das ich überhaupt
halbwegs anschaubare Thumbnails hinbekomme,
aber mittlerweile sind die doch wirklich in Ordnung.
Vor allem jetzt, da ich
auch die Keks-Emotes habe.
Keks-NFT
incoming. Oh ne, bloß nicht.
Ich werde nie ein NFT machen.
Aber ihr wisst, wenn ich
sage, ich werde nie ein NFT machen, ist das eigentlich nur
G-Bait, weil nächste Woche mein nächster NFT kommt.
Es ist immer so.
Umso mehr was abgestritten wird,
umso wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass es passiert.
Du kriegst das Kotzen, wenn du meine
Thumbnails siehst. Aha, warum?
Das müssen wir jetzt etwas genauer
erörtern. Alter!
Keiner mag meine Thumbnails.
Keck, wait, Alter. Was ist da los?
Face-Reveal-NFT.
Ja, genau.
Ne, 100 Thumbnails für 10 Euro.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass da irgendwas Geiles rauskommt.
Zumal, dann müsstest
du ja im Vorfeld schon wissen, was du draufschreibst.
Das weiß ich ja oftmals selbst nicht.
Fünf Minuten, nachdem ich das Video aufgenommen habe.
Immer noch nicht, also.
Hast du vielleicht eine andere Vorstellung als deine User?
Ja, dann müsste ich erstmal wissen, was meine User
für... Ja, erzähl mal.
Erzähl mal.
Also, was würdest du oder was
würdet ihr anders machen? Das ist tatsächlich kein schlechtes...
Kein schlechtes... Wie, was würdet ihr an den
Thumbnails anders machen? Ich bin ja kein krasser
Designer, man.
Echt, keine schlechte Frage.
Okay, das ist einfach
Troll-Stelz, na dann.
Also, was gucken wir uns jetzt für ein Video an?
Achso, wir müssen uns Jibänen lassen von
Levelcap, stimmt.
Mehr Clickbait. Ja, ich sollte unbedingt mehr rote Pfeile
machen.
Gone wrong, gone sexual, Alter.
So.
Xbox making everything
exclusive. Mehr Booba.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Booba wird garantiert ziehen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass
Booba zu meinem Content passt.
So, also.
Lassen wir uns mal von Levelcap
Jibänen. Kurz Musik
ausmachen. Also, Levelcap, was
erzählst du uns denn?
Moment, was?
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ist es laut genug, oder soll ich
noch ein bisschen lauter machen?
Bisschen lauter geht, glaube ich, noch.
So.
So ist gut.
Hast du nur einen Bildschirm? Ne, ich habe zwei Bildschirme.
Ich habe links einen Chat.
Und die Sachen
für das Overlay.
Und
den Rest halt hier drauf.
Glaubst du, Dying Light 2 wird
auch so ein Release-Reinfall wie gefühlt?
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe irgendein Anspiel-Event
Einladung bekommen.
Habe ich aber.
Ne, nicht nur Anspiel-Event. Ich sollte.
Die haben sogar, glaube ich, gefragt, ob ich
irgendein Promotion-Zeug mache.
Wollte ich aber nicht.
Nicht so meins.
Okay.
Lass uns jibänen
von Levelcap.
...
Das verstehe ich.
Das verstehe ich immer nicht, ne.
Dass es immer so einen Fanboy-Krieg ausbricht.
Letztendlich ist es dumm,
irgendwas zu fanboyen in dieser Richtung.
Weil alle
daraus nur Kapital schlagen.
Es wird dir niemand ein Fanboy des Monats-Award
verleihen.
Also du wirst durch Fanboyen nie Vorteile haben.
Das ist einfach so.
Es hat keinen Sinn, sich jetzt irgendwie zu sagen,
jawohl, ich wusste schon immer,
Xbox best, endlich macht Xbox.
Das habe ich ja auch bei mir im Video gelesen.
Endlich macht Xbox Playstation fertig.
Was ja bescheuert ist.
Das kann man da überhaupt nicht reinreprätieren.
Letztendlich wird das nur ausgenutzt,
wenn man Ultra-Fanboyt.
Also ich verstehe den Fanboy-Bohr nicht.
Das wird es auch nicht werden.
Ja gut, Phil Spencer erzählt ja auch viel,
wenn der Tag lang ist.
Phil Spencer hat noch vor zwei Wochen erzählt,
dass, äh, hat er sich noch
damit auseinandergesetzt,
was bei Activision Blizzard gerade so abgeht.
Und dass sie in Zukunft irgendwie
nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten wollen.
Gut, man könnte sagen, er kauft sie.
Das heißt keine Zusammenarbeit mehr.
Aber naja, die erzählen alle viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ist das, oder Chad fragt was,
das sehe ich, da hat er glaube ich recht.
Ist das nicht eher ein emotionales Ding?
Man möchte eine Bestätigung dafür haben,
dass man, ja natürlich ist es,
das ist in vielen Bereichen so,
dass selbst wenn du weißt,
dass es eigentlich Blödsinn ist,
du trotzdem weiterhin darauf beharrst,
weil du musst dir ja sonst eingestehen,
dass du in der Vergangenheit Mist gemacht hast.
Da gibt es sicherlich auch irgendein
psychologisches Phänomen,
Namen dafür.
Ja, ist es.
Aber,
man wird trotzdem,
also die Realität ist halt,
man wird trotzdem keine Vorteile davon haben.
Ist es, aber ist es auf jeden Fall.
Stimmt, das stimmt, was du sagst.
Man hat mehr Spaß an der Xbox,
wenn man Fanbeute stimmt.
Aktuell hat man an der Xbox sonst wenig Spaß.
Im Prinzip gibt es da eigentlich keinen Unterschied mehr.
Blizzard war mal ein Entwickler,
also ursprünglich gehörte Blizzard,
wie war das,
Vivendi, war das nicht mal Vivendi ursprünglich?
Das haben die dann verkauft
und
dann haben die sich zusammengeschlossen
zu Activision Blizzard.
Blizzard an sich gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Man könnte, man könnte höchstens sagen,
Blizzard ist halt der Teil von Activision Blizzard,
der sich um World of Warcraft und solche Sachen kümmert.
Wobei ich mir auch da relativ sicher bin,
was Anti-Cheat und sonst was angeht,
ist das auch übergreifend.
Hat eine smarte Steckdosenleiste.
Der Deal der Woche.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das für eine Seite ist.
Ricola, WLAN-Steckerleiste.
Kann man die Flaschen, weiß ich nicht.
Die Seite sieht mit Blitz,
mit Darkstream, aber ziemlich fail aus.
71 Schweizer Franken, Alter.
Das ist ziemlich teuer.
Na gut, das ist die Schweiz.
In der Schweiz ist alles teuer.
Das ist saumäßig teuer, das Ding.
Ähm, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was sind das für komische Stecker?
Haben die Schweizer andere Stecker oder was?
Ne, hä?
Die Stecker sehen irgendwie falsch aus.
Was sind das für Stecker?
Achso, die Schweizer haben andere Stecker.
Stecker.
Ähm, keine Ahnung, wenn das Tuya-kompatibel ist,
hast du vielleicht die Chance, dass du sie flashen kannst.
Aber die meiste aktuelle Firmware eher nicht.
Also ich würde es nicht kaufen, wenn ich nicht wüsste,
dass ich flashen kann.
Weil ansonsten ist es China-Cloud-Zeug.
Wer hat es erfunden?
Genau.
Okay, schauen wir mal weiter.
Beside his desire to keep the Call of Duty Franchise alive
across Xbox and PlayStation.
And this is great news for fans on both platforms.
However, it should be noted that Spencer specifically mentions
Call of Duty here, which leaves the door open
for Activision Blizzard's other titles like Overwatch and Warcraft.
Could those potentially become Xbox-exclusive titles instead?
Remembering Microsoft with its acquisition of Bethesda...
Also, es ist doch ganz klar.
Die Sachen werden Xbox-exklusiv oder beziehungsweise Xbox Game Pass PC
wie auch immer exklusiv, sollte sich Microsoft davon mehr Geld versprechen,
als sie mit dem...
Release auf der PlayStation einnehmen.
Und nachdem, zumindest was Konsolenverkäufe und sowas angeht,
PlayStation, ich rede nicht nur von Deutschland,
generell ist der Xbox ein bisschen am schwächeln,
auch seit der PS4, also seit der Xbox One ist es dann,
bisschen am schwächeln.
Also sprich, sind die Verkäufe wahrscheinlich bei Sony relativ gut.
Also müssten die ordentlich Kohle damit machen, dass sich das Releasen auf der PlayStation,
nicht lohnt.
Das heißt, die meisten Spiele gehe ich davon aus, wenn die Cross-Plattformen entwickelt sind,
kommen die auch auf der PlayStation raus.
Gut, wissen tut man es nie.
Es könnte immer noch sein, dass Microsoft sagt, auf geht's, kein Bock mehr.
Wir machen jetzt, wir wollen jetzt unsere Sachen boosten oder so.
Aber sehe ich jetzt in nächster Zeit ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Umgedreht wäre das viel besser, wenn mehr PlayStation-Sachen auf dem PC rauskommen würden.
Ich meine, God of War ist jetzt auf dem PC rausgekommen,
soll wohl ein richtig...
...guter, äh, richtig gute Umsetzung sein.
Hatten wir jetzt auch zwei Jahre Zeit.
Wann kam God of War raus?
2020 oder so?
Boy.
Ach, War Thunder, wen interessiert War Thunder?
Es ist immer noch ein heißes Thema, mit dem die News jeden Tag auftaucht.
Wie hat es geschehen? Wer hat am meisten von dem Deal gewonnen?
Warum hat es jetzt geschehen?
Nun, die Wall-Street-Journal berichtet, dass die aufwändigen Verbrechen der Angehörigen
bei Activision Blizzard als Kategorie für...
Planning to leave, ich würde sagen, die Kicken gehen eher raus, aber er möchte nicht, dass
es so aussieht, als würde er gekickt.
... Microsoft, um Activision zu beobachten, über eine mögliche Ausgabe.
Laut dem Artikel, hat Microsoft sich interessiert, in einer Qualifikation, in der er sich interessiert hat.
... in einer Qualifikation, in der er sich interessiert hat.
... …
...
Was juckt mich, was Bobby da erzählt?
Bei ihm wissen wir, dass er auch wirklich sehr viel erzählt,
Tag lang ist.
How Xbox really bought Activision?
Also allein schon das ist
kompletter Blödsinn.
Okay, okay.
Es ist Phil Spencer, das ist der Chef. Ja gut.
Meinetwegen Xbox, ja.
Call of Duty issued a statement on social media
channels during the week announcing the
postponement of Warzone and Vanguard
Season 2 content.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass
Ihr Game zu verbuggt ist?
Also ich spiele
Warzone selbst nicht mehr aktiv. Ich weiß nicht,
wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Seid ihr noch
aktiv Warzone spielen?
Also ich spiele
schon eine Weile nicht mehr aktiv, aber was ich
so mitbekomme, auch von den ganzen Warzone
Content Creators,
kommt Vanguard und
wie heißt diese neue Insel?
Caldera?
Ne. Caldera?
Ist es Caldera?
Bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie die neue Insel heißt.
Kommt nicht gut
an. Zumal das Game wohl
auch alle Nase lang irgendwelche
Gamebreaking Probleme hat.
Und wahrscheinlich
wollen sie das jetzt erstmal ein bisschen auf Vordermann
bringen, bevor die nächste Season kommt.
Was wahrscheinlich auch die richtige Entscheidung ist.
Ja, da sind viele nicht zufrieden
mit. Also bin ich mal gespannt, was da kommt.
Siehste mal, Leute, Leute, ohne Scheiß.
Nochmal ein weiterer
Punkt, warum
Madeira, genau.
Wisst ihr
nochmal ein weiterer Punkt,
warum es richtig dumm war,
Battlefield 2042 rauszubringen?
In dem Zustand, wie es
jetzt ist. Stellt euch mal vor,
Battlefield 2042
würde rauskommen,
in einem guten Zustand
und Warzone würde gleichermaßen
mit diesem Kack-Release schwächeln.
Das wäre das Beste,
was ihnen passieren könnte.
Aber
verkackt.
Einfach nur verkackt.
Also Chat sagt,
kann es sein, dass Microsoft mit dem Deal
eher einen Schritt in Richtung E-Sport machen möchte.
Vielleicht, aber ganz ehrlich,
E-Sport-technisch
ist ja, glaube ich,
Blizzard und Activision somit
der schlechteste Verein, den du dafür
übernehmen kannst.
Bei der Call of Duty-Liga
haben sie irgendwie keinen Plan, was sie richtig machen.
Bei der Overwatch-League haben sie auch keinen Plan,
was sie richtig machen.
StarCraft ist E-Sport mehr oder weniger
dead.
Und die Koreaner spielen da teilweise
wieder StarCraft 1.
Hearthstone.
Hearthstone haben wir noch.
E-Sport, lull.
Ja, Hearthstone haben wir noch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das alleine so trägt.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das nehmen die vielleicht so mit.
Und vielleicht ändern sie auch was daran und bringen das
mal wieder auf Kurs. Aber aktuell kannst du es knicken.
Du wirst ja nicht,
was man an E-Sport-Titeln
von denen haben möchte.
Es kann ja weder StarCraft noch Overwatch
im aktuellen Zustand.
Zumindest nichts von den Blizzard-Spielen sein.
Und
Call of Duty kann es auch nicht sein.
Ja.
Die reden ja schon davon,
dass Battlefield free-to-play werden soll.
Ja, das habe ich auch gelesen. Und ohne Mist,
ich halte diese Sache
mit Battlefield 2042
wird free-to-play oder kriegt ein free-to-play-Ableger,
um die Spieler
nicht zu sehr anzupissen, tatsächlich
für mit die plausibelste
Variante, wie man versucht, das Spiel zu retten.
Dafür würde auch sprechen, dass der neue Battlefield-Chef
Erfahrung mit free-to-play-Spielen hat.
Der neue Battlefield-Chef ist ja der von
Apex Legends und von Titanfall.
Aber hauptsächlich von Apex Legends,
so von was free-to-play angeht.
Das würde passen.
Ich kann es mir tatsächlich vorstellen,
dass, ähm, free-to-play
die
wahrscheinlichste Option ist, damit
irgendwie nochmal Geld zu machen.
Bobby soll ja eine dicke Abfindung bekommen,
laut dem Fall. Ja, das wundert mich nicht. Habe ich ja sogar in meinem Video gesagt.
Habe ich ja sogar in meinem Video gesagt. Habe ich ja sogar in meinem Video gesagt.
Egal, ob der bleibt oder nicht,
aber auf jeden Fall wird er nochmal dicke,
fetten Bonus kriegen für den Deal
und nochmal dicke, fette Abfindung,
wenn er gehen sollte. Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Der Typ ist ja jetzt schon nicht arm, aber dann
ist er halt noch ein paar hundert Millionen reicher.
Wir reden ja nicht hier, ich wollte gerade sagen,
dann ist er ja ein paar Millionen reicher.
Nein, nein, er ist ein paar hundert Millionen reicher.
Es ist nicht einfach so, dass wir hier von
paar Millionchen oder so, nein, von
hundert, ich glaube, der kriegt irgendwie was,
irgendwas zwischen 100 und 250
Millionen Abfindung oder so was.
von 100 und 250 Millionen Abfindung oder so was.
Alter, da geht's mal zur Sache.
Ist überall viel Potential.
Da müssen wir bei Overwatch erstmal was drehen, dass da wieder Potential ist.
Sorry, Chat.
Ich habe irgendwas übersehen.
Irgendwelche Technik-Questions, die beantworte ich natürlich
immer gerne.
Sehr abovus.
Wie kann ich bei Hetzer eine Subdomain machen?
Brauche ich für Let's Encrypt DNS Challenge?
Traffic sagt immer Eintrag nicht gefunden.
Alter.
So, exzellent.
Also, was du machen kannst ist,
du kannst, also es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Entweder nimmst du den Loadbalancer von
Hetzer, der macht das alles für dich. Easy.
Aber du musst deine Domain auf die
Hetzer DNS Server umstellen, dass es
funktioniert.
Wenn du deine Domain auf die Hetzer DNS Server
umgestellt hast, kannst du im DNS
Menü einfach eine neue
Subdomain anlegen.
Und dann brauchst du auch keine DNS Challenge mehr, weil du
den Server extern stehen hast und direkt
darauf zugreifen kannst.
Alternativ,
wenn du das über API machen willst,
angenehmer,
dann würde ich dir tatsächlich empfehlen, nicht den Hetzer
DNS zu nehmen, weil ich glaube, der Hetzer
DNS, schauen wir mal,
weiß ich nicht, ob es da ein
Third-Port-Plugin gibt.
Da gibt es ein Third-Port-Plugin. Okay, dann geht das
wahrscheinlich doch damit. Interessant. Wusste ich
nicht, dass es das gibt. Das könntest du mal probieren.
Aber dann würde ich was anderes nehmen.
Ich würde sowas wie
den Cloudflare DNS nehmen zum Beispiel.
Der Cloudflare DNS ist komplett
kostenlos. Kannst du einen Cloudflare Account machen.
Und lässt sich wunderbar über die
API bedienen und hat
bei allen möglichen
Let's Encrypt
Libraries standardmäßig schon
als Plugin mit dabei. Ich meine, Cloudflare
ist eines der größten Anbieter, die es gibt in dem Bereich.
Das ist denen doch egal.
Deswegen sage ich, die machen vielleicht
einen Free-to-Play-Ableger,
was nicht so offensichtlich ist und die Leute sich angepisst
fühlen.
Tja, ich würde sagen, einfach einen haben.
Ansonsten, ne.
Ich würde mal Barry Base gucken, aber wenn es da keinen
mehr gibt, Pech gehabt erstmal. Muss man
wahrscheinlich abwarten.
Overwatch 2 in der
Versenkung verschwunden.
Traffic hat Hetzner? Wirklich?
Geil. Ja, dann kannst du es da drüber
machen. Ja.
Aber du musst deine Domain auf jeden Fall
so umbiegen, dass die Hetzner DNS Server
verwendet werden. Also muss die Hetzner
Server einstellen bei deinem Domain
Registrar, dass du es
da drüber anlegen kannst.
Ok, schauen wir jetzt erstmal fertig.
...
Ja, das wie gesagt, das würde mich nicht wundern, die müssen ja irgendwas machen.
Und wisst ihr, was mich auch, neben dem, was ich eben schon gesagt habe dazu,
wisst ihr, was mich auch stutzig macht und warum diese Free-to-Play-Option tatsächlich was ist,
was ich auch für immer wahrscheinlicher halte?
Das ist die komplette Funkstille um die Season und um wirklich substanzielle neuen Content.
Die sind einfach, die halten einfach die Klappe.
Da kommt einfach nix.
Hätten die irgendwas in der Pipeline und würden die planen, wirklich demnächst auch was zu releasen,
dann hätten die schon längst riesengroße Dinger gepostet auf Twitter und würden sich drüber auslassen.
Ich, ich gehe davon aus, dass sie das so ähnlich machen wie bei Apex.
Und da haben sie es auch mit Season Pass gemacht.
Ach ja, wo wir gerade dabei sind, Leute, jetzt wo er das gerade zeigt,
wir müssen uns mal zwei Sachen angucken.
Erstens, Battlefield 2042, Spieler-Count, richtig nice.
Also richtig, richtig nice.
Also von 100.000 sind noch 8.000 übrig, wohlgemerkt auf Steam.
Aber auf Origin und der Konsolen wird der Trend ähnlich sein.
Und mein persönliches Highlight der Woche, die Spielerzahlen von New World,
die nicht nur zum ersten Mal deutlich unter 100.000 getroppt sind, nein,
sondern quasi instant auch unter 90.000 und bald unter 80.000 droppen.
Ja, und die bekleckern sich ja immer noch nicht mit Ruhm mit dem Game.
Das Game hat ja, es hat, ich sag mal so, es ist bei weitem nicht in so einem Ultra, na doch, eigentlich schon.
Ganz ehrlich, New World und Battlefield 2042 sind zwar komplett unterschiedliche Spiele
und haben eigentlich auch komplett unterschiedliche Probleme,
aber die Unfähigkeit zeigt sich, zeigt sich bei beiden.
Ich meine, man muss sich mal überlegen, die haben allen Ernstes ein MMO programmiert.
Ein MMO programmiert.
Ich will jetzt nicht von so Sachen reden, wie, dass es kein Content gibt, sonst was.
Habe ich mir ja schon oft genug drüber ausgelassen.
Die haben ernsthaft ein MMO programmiert, wo Hit-Rack-Client-Side ist.
In einem MMO.
Client-Side-Hit-Rack.
Also, wenn du deinen Client laggst, wirst du nie getroffen und bekommst nie Damage.
Warum?
Wie kommt man auf die Idee, ein MMO?
Zu entwickeln, wo die Hit-Rack-Client-Side ist?
Und wie kommt man auf die Idee, zu sagen, ja, das ist okay, das ist ein super, super Five-Head-Plan?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich habe noch nie ein, also, okay, ich muss anders anfangen.
MMOs haben eigentlich immer einen ziemlich holprigen Launch,
gerade am Anfang, wenn sich alles draufstürzt und so.
Da sage ich gar nichts dagegen, aber New World hatte keinen holprigen Start.
New World hatte den schlechtesten Start, den ich je gesehen habe in einem MMO.
Mir geht es nicht um Queues, mir geht es nicht um Server-Crashes,
mir geht es um Sachen, die schlicht und ergreifend eines MMOs unwürdig sind.
Ja, Sachen, Fehler, die sie 2020, 2021, 2022, was weiß ich, wann dieses Spiel tatsächlich entwickelt wurde,
ist ja ewig in Entwicklung gewesen,
Fehler, die Dark Age of Camelot nicht mal gemacht hat.
Ja.
Du konntest Items dupen über einen Vendor, über ein Vault-System.
Items dupen, das sind Sachen, die sind seit Diablo 2 eigentlich gelöste Probleme, zum größten Teil.
Klar, das kommt immer mal wieder vor, aber nicht in diesem Ausmaß.
Du konntest Items dupen, du konntest Gold dupen, du konntest Quests, du konntest quasi Quests,
ich nenne es mal dupen, Quest-Rewards dupen in, also die XP-Rewards in New World.
Wirklich, es ist absoluter Wahnsinn.
Ey, Cyberpunk ist ein Offenbarung.
Also, die haben es geschafft, Fehler zu machen und Unfähigkeit an den Tag zu legen,
in einem neuen MMO 2022 mit der Technologie von heute und der Erfahrung der letzten 20 Jahre,
dass sie Sachen verkackt haben, die EverQuest schon gut hinbekommen hat.
Also, fehlerfrei und nicht exploitable.
Ich weiß echt nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
So, weiter.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, Leute, ich sage es, ich sage es jeden Stream.
Ich sage es jeden Stream.
Aber das Erste, was uns hier im Stream eingefallen ist, als die Portal vorgestellt haben, ist Booster-Server.
Und dann kommt das Spiel raus und das Erste, was in Portal passiert ist,
Booster-Server.
Und da frage ich mich einfach nur, wie hinter dem Mond kann man bei DICE leben,
dass man das nicht im Vorfeld kommen hat sehen.
Es leuchtet mir einfach nicht ein.
Booster-Server.
Letztendlich ist es doch eh egal.
Das Spiel hat ja nichts zum Anlocken.
Jeder, der das Spiel seit Release gespielt hat, eh schon alles unlockt, was er will.
Es gibt nichts mehr, was man anlocken kann.
Ja, sag mal so, doch, es gibt, mache 1000 Kills mit so, meinetwegen, das vielleicht nur.
Aber ansonsten ist alles da.
Red Your Grave sagt, das ist ein guter Punkt, sinnbildlich für aktuelle Spiele, als ob die Leute nicht wissen, was ein gutes Spiel ausmacht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man ein gutes Spiel ausmacht, dann ist es ein gutes Spiel, das man nicht ausmacht.
ja schon selber gemacht haben in der Vergangenheit.
Naja, ich glaube, da spielt vieles mit rein.
Natürlich tragen Publisher und Hersteller und Stonks-Manager
und Leute, die die Spiele quasi in eine monetarisierbare Richtung drücken,
erheblich dazu bei, dass Spiele in diesem Zustand
oder mit diesem Gameplay und diesem Inhalt rauskommen,
wie sie es heutzutage machen.
Aber nur weil jemand mal ein gutes Spiel programmiert hat,
und das ist, finde ich, ein Punkt, der zu selten beleuchtet wird,
deswegen will ich mich da jetzt mal ein bisschen länger zu auslassen,
nur weil jemand mal ein gutes Spiel in der Richtung programmiert hat
oder auch wenn das Team mal ein gutes Spiel programmiert hat,
heißt nicht automatisch, dass ihr nächstes Spiel gut werden muss.
Es kommt auch ganz entscheidend darauf an,
dass man einen gescheiten, nennen wir es mal, Director oder irgendwie sowas hat.
Ich glaube, das beste aktuelle Beispiel ist Back 4 Blood.
Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig,
ich war nie ein großer Left 4 Dead-Spieler, Criner,
aber ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig,
dass Left 4 Dead eigentlich ganz gute Spiele waren,
vor allem im Multiplayer richtig geklänzt haben.
Back 4 Blood ist schlechter als Left 4 Dead,
obwohl es mehr oder weniger das gleiche Team ist.
Woran liegt das?
Naja, wahrscheinlich, weil Valve und irgendwelche Director und Manager bei Valve
die Ahnung davon hatten, was eben gemacht werden muss
und was nicht, das Sagen hatten.
Zumindest so die Definitionen.
Also, da spielt das schon eine Rolle mit.
Also, es war auf jeden Fall nicht nur der Entwickler,
weil dann hätte ja Back 4 Blood auch wahnsinnig geil werden müssen.
Ja, also, da spielt mehreres rein.
Aber natürlich ist auf jeden Fall ein großer Punkt
diese Monetarisierbarkeit von Spielen.
Klar, natürlich.
Ja, das kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Ja, da habe ich jetzt ja gar nichts dran gedacht.
Natürlich, das kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Nur weil der gleiche Name von einem Studio draufsteht oder irgendwas, heißt das noch gar nicht, dass es die gleichen Leute sind.
Guck mal bei Infinity Ward.
Infinity Ward.
Wer ist denn heute aus Call of Duty 4 Zeiten noch bei Infinity Ward?
Wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer.
Fortnite Dance.
Also die schlimmste Erfahrung, die ich mal hatte mit einem Fortnite Dance, war am Südbahnhof irgendeine Gruppe Zwölfjähriger,
die allen Ernstes sich vor die Straßenbahn gestellt haben am Südbahnhof
und dort den Loser Dance gemacht haben in Richtung des Straßenbahnfahrers.
Das war so cringe, das allein schon anzusehen.
Aber so ist das halt.
Die Fortnite-Jugend von heute, Leute.
Ist das nur bei mir so oder hat Max wirklich ein Knistern im...
Oh, hab ich, hab ich.
Sekunde, muss ich mal gucken.
Ich hoffe nicht.
Bla bla bla Test, hab ich ein Knistern im Ton, wenn ich spreche?
Blub blub blub blub blub.
Nein.
Bla bla bla Test, hab ich ein...
Da knistert nix.
Was ist ein Loser Dance?
Okay, Leute, da müsst ihr jetzt durch.
Da müsst ihr jetzt durch.
Es gibt Leute, die wissen nicht, was ein Loser Dance ist.
Das ist der Loser Dance.
Pains Champ.
Weil er so einen L vorm Kopf macht.
Ja.
Jetzt, für alle, die es noch nicht wussten.
Jetzt wisst ihr.
Was der Fortnite Loser Dance ist.
Ja, man hätte auch drauf verzichten können,
aber ich dachte, mit dieser Bildungslücke muss ich schließen.
Ja, Fortnite-Kinders in Frankfurt.
So, weiter.
Wir sind immer noch...
Ich hab jetzt, glaube ich, bei einem 9-Minuten-Video 30 Minuten geschwätzt.
Egal.
Nein, Tänze gibt's noch nicht in Battlefield 2042,
aber ich denke, es wird nicht mehr lange dauern.
Ich meine, es gibt immerhin jetzt den Weihnachtsmann Boris
und den Cowboy McKay.
Also, da wird's wahrscheinlich zu Dances nicht mehr lange dauern.
Ich werde für den fett Yoshi-Dance.
NF!
Knallgas, bring die nicht auf Ideen.
Bring die bitte nicht auf Ideen.
Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle im Klaren,
dass mittlerweile, sobald das Wort NFT fällt,
bei den ganzen Top-Managern mittlerweile die Augen auf Dollar gehen.
Sag's nicht so laut, ja?
Sonst haben wir bald NFT-Tänze in Battlefield.
Wobei man ja sagen muss,
dass NFT-Tänze genauso Schwachsinn sind wie NFT-Bilder,
weil das eigentlich...
Welche Talken weder was mit den Tänzen noch mit den Bildern zu tun hat.
Aber die, äh, ich glaube, die Zusammenhänge erschließt sich nur den wenigsten, ja.
Weiß, weiß ich nicht, nein.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir IBM, nein, das ist ja nicht,
Lenovo sind's ja, Lenovo-Syncpads.
Aber kann ich weder großartig empfehlen, noch, äh,
was das Gegenteil von empfehlen, abraten.
Wir können uns gleich mal ein Video zum Thema NFTs angucken.
Ich, ich, ich hab ein Video irgendwo hier noch offen, der erklärt das ganz gut.
Ach ja, und für alle Leute, die schon mal Git verwendet haben,
wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass ihr schon ganz viele NFTs erstellt habt?
Jedes Git-Commit ist quasi ein Talken.
Also richtig...
Also Programmierer sind hier quasi die richtigen NFT-Kings schon.
Shit, meine ich, shit, shit, genau.
Müsste ich echt mal machen, ja.
Hä, warum nicht?
Alles verkaufen.
Dann hast du eine Seite, da steht dann dran,
dieses Comet gehört Easy Elite, äh, Easy, Easy Light.
Gut, das ist nicht direkt übertragbar, das stimmt schon.
Gut, schauen, wir schauen jetzt das Video endlich mal fertig.
Und kann jetzt sein, dass da drei Stunden verbraucht werden.
...have their health capped at 1 HP, meaning they could not be eliminated.
This HP glitch would even keep players alive if they ventured outside of the playable area.
Needless to say, fans on PC have been begging for a fix over the holiday season.
Kevin Johnson, one of Battlefield's community managers, engaged with the community over on Reddit
to share that the team is live.
He's looking into things and that a fix is coming soon.
Now, on the topic of Star Wars, the new LEGO Star Wars The Skywalker Saga
finally received its public release date of April 5th.
However, recent reports of severe developer crunch
has certainly cast some shade on the new gameplay reveal.
One such report has revealed that the game's development included crunch,
mismanagement and high staff turnover.
According to both past and current developers interviewed,
both TT Game Studios based in the UK encouraged a culture where,
working overtime was practically mandatory.
One employee even shared that the team was told,
if people don't start doing overtime, there's going to be problems.
Along with these intense hours and harsh conditions,
reports indicate both TT Game Studios were hostile towards women on their teams.
Comments on their physical appearance...
Das ist ja mittlerweile, das scheint mir ja mittlerweile Standard zu sein, ja.
Du müsstest fast eine Liste umgedreht machen, wo es gute Arbeitsbedingungen für Frauen gibt.
Du kannst ja mittlerweile fast schon default von ausgehen, dass es das nicht ist.
Das hörst du ja quasi aus allen Ecken.
Wobei, wahrscheinlich tut man den meisten Unrecht.
Wahrscheinlich ist es wirklich so, dass es bei den meisten Studios absolut in Ordnung ist.
Und halt die Extremfälle immer wieder hier überall breitgetreten werden.
...or bullying, not to mention lower wages.
And with serious technical issues plaguing the game's development since 2017,
it's almost a miracle the developers got this game to where it appears to be today.
Unfortunately, at the expense of the workforce.
Halo Infinite has added a brand new deathmatch,
a variant called Attrition.
This mode is part of the Cyber Showdown event, lasting until January 31st.
It pits two teams of four against each other with a pool of eight lives per team.
Once those lives have been depleted, a fun take on sudden death ensues.
And instead of simply respawning, you will remain in a down state,
unless one of your teammates manages to revive you.
If all four players on one team are eliminated, they lose the round.
The cherry on top is the end-of-round danger zone.
This phase of the round slowly restricts itself,
forcing everyone into much tighter engagements.
Halo fans have quickly rallied around this limited-time mode, praising it immensely.
There's always room for a comeback, and tensions are kept high throughout the entire round.
Dying Light 2 is just weeks away from launching in February, and developers at Attrition
als ich den ersten Trailer dazu gesehen habe.
Daniel, 0,31 Monat, danke schön für den Zap.
Okay, jetzt muss er ein bisschen Interaction baiten für das Video, das ist wichtig für den YouTube-Algorithmus, das kenne ich.
Alter, oh hell, 16 Monate, danke schön für den Zap.
Während dieses Jahrs Awesome-Games-Done-Quick-Event, das unglaublich 3,4 Millionen für Charities erhöht hat,
hat einer der Speedrunner, McCrizz, den 2019-Sekiro-Head-On versucht, es so schnell wie möglich zu erreichen, mit einem Twist.
Mitch hat die Spiele in nur zwei Stunden veröffentlicht, während Blond-
Sehe ich das richtig? Der hat das Spiel durchgespielt? Mit Augenbinde, oder wie?
Das ist doch scheiße, Alter, die Leute sind echt hart drauf.
... blindfolded.
Er ist nur einer der drei Spieler, die das Spiel jemals gemacht haben.
Und das in der Welt.
From Software Games bietet normalerweise einen steilen Lernkurs, und Sekiro ist nicht anders.
Das Spiel fokussiert sich auf Paarung und Abweichung, was sich überrascht, dass es sich sehr gut an blindfolded Runden handelt,
da die Zeitgründe aufgrund von Hören basiert.
Und um nicht von dieser wirklich beeindruckenden Speedrun zu wegzunehmen, sollte es erwähnt werden,
dass Mitch mit einem der kürzesten Endungen von Sekiro gekämpft hat.
Mit dem gesagt, ist eine riesige Menge der Geduld und Spielwahrnehmung noch notwendig, um so etwas zu machen,
und es ist ein unglaubliches Erlebnis.
Und das war's.
Das war's für diese Woche von Gaming.
Wie immer, Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen, und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.
Von der Art Abteilung bis zum Programmieren, bis zum Game Design an sich.
Und das ist halt was, wo ich mir denke.
Ich selbst habe noch nie ein Spiel entwickelt, deswegen denke ich mir das nur, dass es ähnlich ist zu anderen Softwareprojekten,
dass du Kreativität schlecht, also , dass du schlecht kreative Ideen unter Druck hast,
beziehungsweise mit jemand, der dir im Nacken sitzt.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Du, du kannst nicht machen.
Du kannst da bestimmt was abliefern, aber der neueste Geniestreich wird es nicht werden.
Daniel Lohle, danke für den Sub.
Meinst du, dass Microsoft nächstes Jahr Call of Duty retten könnte?
Also bezüglich Skill-Based Matchmaking hätten sie noch...
Naja, die Microsoft könnte...
Naja gut, nächstes Jahr. Nächstes Jahr ist ja dieses Jahr im Endeffekt.
Also daran werden die nichts mehr machen können.
Aber Microsoft ist ja nicht der Retter.
Also ich habe jetzt auch bei mir in den Kommentaren gelesen, viele Leute, die sagen,
ja, jetzt endlich besteht wieder die Chance auf ein gutes Call of Duty.
Ja, besteht die Chance darauf, dass Microsoft da irgendwie Entwicklung eingreift und da was umstellt.
Aber man muss halt sagen, Call of Duty verkauft sich trotzdem immer noch gut.
Und ist quasi ein sicheres, fettes Plus einmal im Jahr.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Bedarf Microsoft daran sieht, da überhaupt was umzustellen.
Zumal Skill-Based...
...Matchmaking zwar für uns der Abfuck ist, aber im Großen und Ganzen rein aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht wahrscheinlich die bessere Entscheidung.
Und deswegen ist es fraglich, ob Microsoft das überhaupt als Problem sieht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Versteht mich nicht falsch, ich bin absolut der Feind von Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Ich will Skill-Based Matchmaking sagen, beschissenste Sache überhaupt.
Eigentlich für alle Spieler, aber für den Hersteller ist es aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht wahrscheinlich besser, Skill-Based Matchmaking zu haben.
Die Aufsichtsbehörden...
Das ist richtig, ja.
Das kommt auch noch dabei.
Und der Plan ist ja eh, dass es bis 2023, wenn das alles durchgeht, läuft.
Aber ganz im Ernst, es gab ja größere Sachen schon, die aufgekauft wurden.
Oder, was weiß ich, Disney hat viel aufgekauft und was haben die auch zugestimmt?
Letzte Woche in einem Video gehört war, finde ich, ein ganz gutes Argument.
Also, das wird wahrscheinlich durchgehen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Kreativität wird bestens mit Scrum-Arbeitsweise gehen.
Findest du?
Also, ich finde, wenn das richtig geht...
Wenn das richtig gemacht ist, nicht quasi zu sagen, wir machen Scrum, um es dann nicht zu machen.
Also, wisst ihr, ich meine nicht einfach nur, sich auf die Fahne zu schreiben und dann einfach so weiterzumachen, wie immer.
Finde ich, ist, sag mal so, Agilität in Maßen und richtig gemacht, durchaus was Kreativität förderliches.
Weil, da kannst du die Sachen selbst ein bisschen einteilen und festlegen, was du für den nächsten Sprint machen willst.
Und sowas in der Regel.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das prinzipiell schlecht für die Kreativität ist.
Oder aber du sagst mir warum.
Vielleicht überzeugt mich das.
Vielleicht sagst du, ja, aus diesen Gründen und deswegen geht das nicht.
Kann ja sein.
Habe ich da noch nicht dran gedacht.
Call of Duty hat doch jetzt auch kein Community-Management.
Haben sie nicht mehr?
Früher hatten sie das immer.
Stimmt, da war doch was, ja.
Aber Microsoft kann eh alles kaufen.
Microsoft hat so krass mega viel.
Geld.
Die machen mehr Geld als Nvidia und Netflix zusammen.
Wahrscheinlich noch mehr.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Der Lockpicking-Loyal.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt an, wie er zwei Minuten im Schloss einfach nur scharf anschaut und es dann automatisch aufgeht.
Zeig mal her.
King Loyal.
Blackburn.
High Level Self Defensive.
...Bike Lock in the Store was one I had never seen before.
Ah, Moment. Chat. Chat. Was?
Sprint. Zumindest bei uns wird nicht von dem Team, sondern von dem Manager und Product auch lange geplant.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich doof.
Weil das ist ja gerade der Sinn.
Das ist halt, wenn man Agilität nicht richtig macht.
Das ist halt, wenn man sagt, man ist agil, aber man ist gar nicht richtig agil.
Dass natürlich ein Projektleiter in irgendeiner Art und Weise da Mitsprache hat, was Features priorisiert werden müssen, was nicht, was anderes.
Aber das ist ja eines der Hauptgedanken von der, also ein Haupt, ich hab mal dieses tatsächlich, dieses agile Manifest nicht komplett gelesen, aber mich damit mal auseinandergesetzt.
Der hauptsächliche Punkt von dieser ganzen Agilität ist ja, dass Entwickler und Manager sich weniger auseinandersetzen müssen miteinander.
Also dass Entwickler nicht abgefuckt werden von Managern und Managern trotzdem noch ein bisschen Steuerungsmöglichkeiten auf die Projekte haben.
Das ist ja eigentlich der Kerngedanken dieser ganzen Agilität.
So, wenn jetzt natürlich, also und dass das Entwicklerteam sich halt mehr selbst organisiert.
Wenn jetzt natürlich alles, was das ausmacht, quasi nicht gemacht wird und trotzdem gesagt wird, wir sind super agil, dann ist es diese typische Agilität, die wir auch bei uns auf der Arbeit haben.
Wir sagen, wir sind krass modern und agil, machen es aber nicht.
Ein Beispiel auf, Leute, ein Beispiel von letzter Woche.
Wie das bei uns so ist.
Das muss ich jetzt einfach mal erzählen.
Hat jetzt nicht direkt was hier mit Scrum und sowas zu tun, aber wir sind seit Jahren dabei, mal unsere, wie nennt man das so, über Jahre, sagen wir mal, in Zusammenarbeit entstandenen Prozesse in irgendwas Offizielles umzuwandeln.
Wir haben jede Menge ITIL-Experten und jede Menge Prozessexperten und sonst was.
specifications, das, was sich bei uns etabliert hat, irgendwie schriftlich mal festzuhalten und wagenbedingungen, hier ist ein ScreaMoney fest, zumindest das schriftlich festzulegen.
So, das machen die Jahre bei uns schon, das ist wirklich, die letzten drei, vier, fünf Jahre sind die da dabei und...
Und, letztens...
Ok, ich muss noch ein bisschen mehr drum herum auszählen.
Also, wir haben einmal die Woche so ein Meeting, wo Wartungsarbeiten, wo produktive Wartungsarbeiten stattfinden.
wartungsarbeiten besprochen werden das nennt sich change advisory board das ist auch so was super
super agiles das kennt vielleicht der eine oder andere von euch auch er ist irgend so ein eitel
geschiss und da ist es wichtig und man würde davon ausgehen dass grundlegend fest gilt also
dass erstmal grundlegend definiert ist welche wartungsarbeiten überhaupt in dieses change
advisory board gebracht werden müssen und welche nicht so und wir haben letzte woche
wartungsarbeiten gemacht an entwicklungssystemen ich betone ein entwicklungssystem also an
irgendwelchen kisten die dastehen das entwickler was testen können nix nix live gar nichts also
weiter entfernt von produktiver umgebung kannst du nicht sein so und dann hat doch allen ernstes
irgendjemand in in der runde erzählt so nach dem motto warum war
an die wartungsarbeit nicht angekündigt weil die angekündigt werden müssen weil
das entwicklungssysteme sind who cares und dann auf daraufhin haben wir den chef vom
change management zu einem meeting eingeladen und haben ihn gefragt sagt mal welches also ab
welcher so ab welchem status muss denn überhaupt ein change angekündigt werden in diesem change
advisory board und dann
meinte er so, natürlich nur für Live-Systeme,
nur für produktive Systeme muss der das.
Und dann haben wir ihn gefragt,
okay, kannst du uns noch mal
einen Link schicken, wo
das steht? Und dann meinte er,
eins darf gibt's nicht.
Das heißt, wir haben das,
aber wir haben das Grundlegendste auf der Welt
nicht definiert.
Für was es da ist und was da rein muss.
Das ist einfach nur in den Köpfen der Leuten wieder drin.
Das ist halt,
das kommt halt raus, wenn man so
tun will, als macht man was, aber macht's
gar nicht.
Das ist so wirklich das Grundlegendste
überhaupt.
Viel grundlegender kann eigentlich eine
Definition bei Prozessen und Abläufen nicht
sein, als, ne, also
wenn man sagt, wir haben ein
globales unternehmensweites
Meeting, wo Wartungsarbeiten vorgestellt
werden müssen.
Das erste, was du definieren musst, ist,
was muss da rein und was
nicht? Und das haben wir nirgendwo
stehen.
Das ist der typische
Fall von, wir tun
so, als sind wir krass eitel
und modern und sonst was, aber sind's
halt nicht. Und machen weiter wie bisher
und schreiben uns einfach nur auf die Fahne, wir sind's.
Das ist so geil.
Oh Mann.
Der Product Manager, das kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Das sind auch so Dinge,
die, also fürs gleiche
Projekt, ne, das sind einfach so Sachen, die sind
komplett widersprüchlich.
Ja.
Das haben wahrscheinlich viele.
Leute, soll ich euch mal sagen,
was die beste Dokumentation
ist, die ich auf der Arbeit
habe? Wahrscheinlich kommt
ihr drauf. Meine
Bash-History.
Ich hab meine Bash-History von, okay,
es ist eigentlich ZSH.
Es ist eigentlich ZSH, aber ich sag jetzt einfach mal Bash
der Einfachheit halber.
Ich hab meine Bash-History schon vor
Jahren auf Unlimited gestellt.
Ich hab eine Bash-History von,
was weiß ich, 180.000 Zeilen
oder so mittlerweile.
Meine Bash-History.
Irgendjemand fragt mich, kennst du
Server XY? Ich drück STRG-R,
such meine Bash-History durch.
Ach ja, ja, kenn ich, kenn ich.
Kennst du, weißt du, mit welchem
User man sich auf Server XY einloggen kann?
Sekunde, STRG-R, Server
Nr. Ah ja, weiß ich, weiß ich, der da ist es.
Ah, logisch, ja.
Bash-History.
Was nicht in meiner Bash-History
steht, existiert nicht. Ganz einfach.
Tribulon, danke
für 25 Monate Subscription.
Huge Sub. Hyper-Subscription.
Ja, ist echt so.
Bash-History, die Bash-History ist die beste
Logomenation, die ich auf der Arbeit hab.
Ist echt so.
Ich hab sogar einen Backup von meiner Bash-History.
Ja.
Ich hab einen Backup, ich hab sogar
einen Backup von meiner Bash-History.
Bash-History
ist das Wichtigste.
Leute, ich hab bei mir mittlerweile, ich hab
letztens nachgeguckt, weil das war witzig.
Ich wollte auf GitHub,
also ich hab einen extra, ich hab einen zweiten Account,
für das GitHub der Firma
und ich wollte dort
meinen SSH-Key hinterlegen.
Und da hab ich mal seit Jahren wieder in mein
SSH-Key-Verzeichnis reingeguckt
und mal geschaut, was da drinnen
liegt, Leute. Ich hab, ungelogen,
16 SSH-Keys
da drinnen liegen. 16 SSH-Key-Paare.
ID-RSA
ID-DSA
ID-ID-
Irgendwas. Ich hab alles.
Ich hab alles liegen. 16 SSH-Key-Paare.
16 SSH-Key-Paare.
Und ich hab dann einfach random irgendeins genommen
und hab's in GitHub
copy-pasted. Muss man ja, dass man
pushen, pullen kann ohne Passwort. Dann braucht man
eine Key. Und dann sagt
mir GitHub, dieser Key ist
kompromittiert. Den darfst du nicht
verwenden. Und dann hab ich nachgeguckt,
was ist denn das für ein Key?
Und dann bin ich rausgekommen, das ist noch
ein Debian-Key von
2008.
Kennt noch einer
Debian-SSH?
Kennt das noch einer?
Get-Random-Number-Return-4?
Das war von 2008
oder sowas. Also das ist ja nur ein Witz dazu.
Also Debian hat
quasi den Random-Generator
gefixt.
Das Problem war, dass das gefixte dann am Ende
nur noch irgendwie 60.000 verschiedene Random-Nummern
ausgegeben hat, anstatt Milliarden.
Und ich hatte noch einen Key von 2008,
den ich mit einem damalig
verpackten Debian ausgestellt habe.
Das musst du dir nicht mal vorstellen.
Ich hab echt SSH.
Historie der letzten
ähm
das ist jetzt 15 Jahre.
Ja. Ach ja, alte
Jira-Tickets suche ich auch öfters.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gerade wenn irgendjemand, also was bei uns
auch oft so ist, da kommt dann irgendjemand
an und sagt, äh
System XY, bla bla bla, soll irgendwas
gemacht werden. Da denke ich mir so, hä?
Was ist das denn? Ich hab das Gefühl,
das wissen Windows, da sind wir doch überhaupt nicht für zuständig.
Und dann wird erstmal alte Jira-Tickets
durchsucht, wer damals das System für den Debian-Key
NS beauftragt hat und sagt,
haha, sind wir nicht für zuständig.
Ja, das kommt auch öfters vor bei uns.
Nein, das mach ich nicht. Muss ich ja auch nicht.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich mein Notebook mit
mit Linux drauf.
Jira, genau.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Gucken wir mal weiter. Also.
Ja, genau. Ich muss jetzt sehen, wie der das
Lock aufmacht. Ganz wichtig.
Nee, der schneidet da ja nicht durch.
Also, ich
predikte das Video mal. Der nimmt einen,
in seiner geilen Tools, wackelt
dreimal im Schloss und es ist auf.
Ein Hecksaw?
Was ist denn ein Hecksaw?
Das ist, das ist, das ist
eine Säge, mit der man hacken kann?
Oder, oder ist das einfach eine ganz
normale Säge?
Aber es sind nur sechs Diske
drin. Also, es sollte nicht
so schwer sein, sie zu öffnen.
Lass uns es mal probieren.
Das erste, was wir tun werden,
ist, all diese Diske
so weit wie die Uhr geht,
dann werde ich
den Pick, den ich mit dem Billen
habe, und setze es so, dass wir
die Tension aus dem
Disknummer finden.
Finde Disknummer 2 und
schiebe es in den Clickout auf 4.
Okay, nice little click out of 2.
Click out of 3.
4 feels like it's in a gate.
Probably a zero cut.
Click out of 5.
Little click on 6.
Let's go back to that zero cut.
Nur ein kleiner Klick, nur ein kleiner Klick, Leute.
And set disk number 1.
And that's exactly what happened.
Easy.
Okay, folks, as you saw,
we got into that pretty quickly.
But that's not the end of the story.
This thing is cheap.
$17 is the MSRP,
but I paid only $9.
So, if that's all you have
to spend, it is a great value.
Even if it is a mediocre
lock. In any case,
that's... Easy.
Smart Home Tour, fully automated.
Okay, die Videos
von dem gucke ich mir immer gerne an.
Da ist auch schon einiges an Inspiration dabei gewesen
für meine Heimautomatisierung.
Was ich bei ihm nicht mag, ist,
dass der so
Alexa und Google
Fanboy ist
und alles irgendwie über Voice Assistant steuert.
Das ist ja nichts für mich.
Aber gucken wir uns das trotzdem mal an.
Ja, ja.
Was hat er denn da am Start?
Tesla Charger?
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, was das ist?
Was ist das? Irgendwelche Batterien?
Hey, what's up? Welcome to our house.
It's been a while since our last tour video.
And I can't wait to show you all my favorite smart devices
and automations I'm using around here.
Zeig.
I set up everything myself, so
anyone could do any of this.
Batterien von Solarpanels.
Ah, verstehe.
Was ist denn das da oben?
Ist das ein Beamer?
Hat er denn... Nee, Liftmaster.
Nein, das ist der Motor.
Ist das da oben der Motor fürs Tor?
Das da? Der Liftmaster?
Ich hätte erst gedacht, das ist ein Beamer.
Das ist der Motor.
Übrigens, ganz wichtig.
LED-Panels in der Garage.
Mit einem super...
Oh, das hat aber keinen hohen
Waff-Faktor.
Mit diesem Schalter hier rüber.
Warum hat der überhaupt eine Steckdose da an der Decke?
Richtig, richtig pfeifert, Alter.
Ist sogar...
Gut, bei den Amis funktioniert das.
Ami-Häuser.
Oben drüber ist wahrscheinlich das Wohnzimmer.
Und er bohrt einfach ein Loch durch die Decke und ist da.
Das ist bei uns halt ein bisschen schwieriger.
Auf.
So, hier in the family room we have the frame TV
and it's the 2021 version
that's 65 inches.
It doesn't have high specs, but we really
like this TV because it displays
art when the TV is off.
Wo sitzen die denn?
And we added these little white bezels,
snap-on things on the outside of the TV.
What's cool about those is that it makes
the TV match the other
pictures on the wall since they have
some other ones with white frames.
And it just looks like another...
Ich würde sagen, ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht.
Natürlich kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
so nach dem Motto, oh, warum verbraucht der Strom?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass der Stromverbrauch
relativ gering ist in diesem Art-Modus.
Und eines der wirklich
nicht sonderlich hübschen Sachen von Fernseher,
von aktuellen Fernseher im Wohnzimmer ist,
dass du dort halt einfach zwei Meter
ähm...
so ein zwei Meter
schwarzen
Viereck hast.
Ich meine, es hat schon was, oder?
Ist schon cool. Aber wo sitzen die?
Ach hier, hier, okay.
Eigentlich müsste ja hier ein Sofa sein,
weil ansonsten ist der zu weit weg.
Die sitzen ganz schön weit weg hier.
Egal.
Ja, das habe ich bei mir auch.
Das habe ich bei mir auch.
Also ich kriege auch eine Notification,
wenn es klingelt.
Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen,
man hört auch, wenn es klingelt.
Habe ich gehört. Also ich habe gehört,
man hört, wenn es klingelt.
Ja, beim Vorbeilaufen ist tatsächlich cool,
aber das funktioniert auch bloß
mit den Amis, mit einem eigenen Hof.
Bei uns auf der Straße läuft
laufend einer vorbei.
Typische Ami
Kokona-Schalter ist das wieder,
was du einfach so in die Wand
sägen kannst.
Sowas würde ich bei mir nie im Leben
in die Wand bekommen, weil ich
eine Wand aus Steinen habe und nicht aus Holz.
Manchmal ist es tatsächlich ganz praktisch,
weil dann kann man sowas da dran machen.
Das geht bei mir nicht.
Das stimmt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also was er uns damit sagen will,
und da gebe ich ihm recht, ist,
es ist sinnvoller,
einen Lichtschalter zu automatisieren,
als die Lampe an sich,
weil gerade Leute,
die technisch nicht so versiert sind,
drücken lieber einen Schalter
und ich ehrlich gesagt abends,
wenn ich irgendwie ins Bett gehe auch,
die drücken lieber einen Schalter,
anstatt sie in irgendeine App
ein- und auszuschalten.
Deswegen sind so Sachen wie die Shellys
wunderbar, da hast du ein Relay,
was dann letztendlich die Lampe schaltet.
Kannst du über den Schalter ein- und ausschalten
oder über WLAN-Triggern.
Das ist das Beste aus beiden Welten, finde ich.
Ja, aber es ist nicht die Frage,
ist es möglich, irgendwie ein Loch
in die Wand zu sägen,
oder ein Loch in die Wand zu schneiden.
Klar ist das möglich, aber erstens
ist der Aufwand ein riesen Unterschied.
Zwischendurch nimmst du eine Säge,
wie bei den Amis, und machst das hier
und saust dir die halbe Etage damit ein.
Und die Frage ist halt auch,
willst du einfach so in eine Steinwand
20 mal 20 Loch sägen oder so?
Schneiden,
oder wie auch immer man das nennt.
So ein Ding habe ich bei mir,
so ein Ding habe ich beispielsweise hinter mir
gesehen, wenn ich die Tür aufmache,
geht das Licht automatisch an.
Die sitzen ganz schön weit weg, oder?
Findet ihr nicht,
dass das ziemlich weit weg vom Fernseher ist?
Vielleicht bin ich
aber einfach nur so Boomer,
und meine Augen sind so schlecht.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich hier sitzen,
dass ich wenigstens was habe davon,
dass ich so einen großen Fernseher habe.
Also ich habe glaube ich einen 75,
wenn ich jetzt nicht Mist erzähle,
habe ich glaube ich einen 75 Zoll Fernseher.
Und ich sitze, wenn ich denn mal Fernseh gucke,
so da, da ungefähr würde ich sagen,
von der Entfernung her.
Also ich bin wahrscheinlich
sogar zu nah dran.
Egal.
So, ich bin jetzt hier
auf dem Fernsehsensor,
der meine Frau gefunden hat.
Einfach umdrehen.
Ja, meine Frau hat einen Pro,
wenn es um Smart-Technologie
um ihr Haus geht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine gute Sache ist.
So, hier auf dieser Seite des Raumes
haben wir einen Echo 4. Gen
auf einer Batteriebasis.
Und ich dachte, es wäre eine gute Idee,
es zu verstecken,
weil wir schon ein bisschen
mit dem Ring zu tun haben.
Bin absolut kein Voice-Assistent-Fan.
Oh, Ring! Ring ist auch so ein Ding,
was mir nicht ins Haus kommt.
Ich habe da Z-Wave-Sensoren.
Nicht nur Z-Wave,
eine Mischung habe ich.
Z-Wave und Zigbee-Sensoren.
Billiges AliExpress
geht seit Jahren ohne Batterie zu wechseln
und funktioniert einfach.
Und lässt sich besser integrieren als das Ringzeug.
Aquara habe ich auch, ja.
Die Aquara-Sensoren sind richtig gut,
weil die sind billig und funktionieren wunderbar.
Da kriegst du für 6 Euro einen Fenster-Sensor.
Das haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Jetzt gehen wir zum nächsten Zimmer,
das ist wahrscheinlich mein Lieblings-Zimmer
in unserem ganzen Haus.
Es ist unser Theater-Zimmer.
Wir haben einen 120-Inch-Screen.
Ach, der hat nochmal ein eigenes Theater.
Ach, Moment.
War das nicht so?
Der hat doch letztes Jahr schon mal sein Haus gezeigt.
Hinter dem, wo die den Fernseher haben,
hat er die Küche.
Also die Kinder gucken Fernseh,
während die Eltern in der Küche sind,
oder irgendwie sowas.
Das war so viel Spaß,
Filme zu sehen und Spiele zu spielen.
Wir haben ein Dolby Atmos-System
mit Sprechgeräten im Garten
und einen Denon-Rechiever.
Wir benutzen auch eine Xbox Series X
für Spiele und Medien.
Wir haben ein paar Smart-Lightings,
die meine Kinder lieben,
aber ich liebe sie ein bisschen mehr.
Und wie ich sie kauf,
meine Kinder lieben sie,
aber ich mag sie.
Wenn du dir diese Dinger fertig kaufst,
ist es teilweise übertrieben teuer.
Also unverhältnismäßig teuer.
Wenn du dir mal überlegst,
was die Hardware kostet,
da ist ein Microcontroller drin,
ein paar LED-Leisten,
ein paar LED-Stripes
und ein Plastikgehäuse.
Das hat einen Materialwert von 20 Euro
oder so ein Ding
und wird dann teilweise verkauft
für 140 und sowas.
Das ist brutals teuer, Alter.
Home Assistant.
Das finde ich gut.
Da muss ich sagen,
das würde ich wahrscheinlich ähnlich machen.
Dashboards sind praktisch.
Es ist immer ganz praktisch,
wenn du erstens die Sachen natürlich
von deinem Smartphone, Tablet
oder sonst was bedienen kannst,
aber du hast ja nicht immer und überall
dein Smartphone oder dein Tablet dabei.
Und wenn du irgendwo gerade bist
und willst schnell was machen
dann ist das echt cool.
Deswegen, bei mir ist es nicht
so super sophisticated wie bei ihm
mit so einem Arm am Stuhl.
Ich habe unten im Flur einen Dashboard hängen
und ich habe oben im Flur einen Dashboard hängen.
Sieht ein bisschen so aus wie bei ihm.
Bloß, dass ich einen Amazon Fire HD 10
verwende als Dashboard-Tablet.
Nicht so ein kleines Kackding.
So kann ich den Projektor automatisieren.
So kann ich mit dem kleinen Tablet
einfach nur einen Knopf drücken
und es wird alles aktivieren.
Insbesondere den Projektor, den Sound, die Lichter,
alles.
Und dann, wenn es Zeit ist, einen Film zu sehen,
drücke ich noch einen Knopf.
Alle Lichter verändern sich.
Ich glaube, das gefällt ihm.
Ich glaube, das gefällt ihm richtig.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mir das vorstelle?
Der geht dann abends mit seiner Familie
rein in den Raum und die gucken fern.
Ich bin am Captain-Sessel
und ich mache die Steuerung.
Ich glaube, das findet er cool.
Ist ja auch cool.
So nach dem Motto, ich habe das Kommando hier jetzt.
Ich mache jetzt das, ich mache jetzt das,
ich drücke jetzt hier.
Und wahrscheinlich, weil die Frau sagt,
ach nee, mach du das mal lieber.
Und wenn was nicht geht,
wenn was nicht geht,
kann die Frau wahrscheinlich anhören,
ja, warum muss das auch so kompliziert sein?
Hättest du nicht einfach einen Knopf hinmachen können
oder sowas?
Kann ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Also, wenn ich sein Haus richtig in Erinnerung habe,
ist die Kitchen direkt hinter dem,
was wir eben mit dem Fernseher gesehen haben.
Alter, das ist ja ein riesen Motion-Sensor.
Sick Motion-Sensor.
Die gibt's, die gibt's schon.
Die sind nur so.
Aha.
Okay, das finde ich praktisch.
Ich kann einfach diesen Schlauch öffnen
und es gibt einen versteckten Knopf.
Und ich kann das Licht auslösen.
Hier haben wir ein Echo Show 15.
Äh.
Warum?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Okay, noch ein weiteres Dashboard.
Und ich liebe, wie groß dieses Display ist.
Ach nee, das ist ein Echo-Dashboard.
Ein Echo-Dings.
Nee, nee, nee, gehen wir mal fort.
Du kannst das Display sehen,
wenn du in der Küche sitzt oder stehst.
Ich denke, größere Smart Displays
sind das, worauf es in Zukunft geht.
Hier ist ein
Ecobee-Thermostat.
Ich liebe die Ecobee-Thermostate.
Kommt bei mir auch nicht ins Haus.
Alles mit irgendwelchen komischen Cloud-Services
oder so will ich nicht haben.
Ich frage mich, wie es bei ihm im Haus aussieht,
wenn sein Internet mal nicht funktioniert.
Ich meine, ich brauche doch keinen Cloud-Service
für irgendwie einen Thermostat.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Man kann es auch übertreiben.
Es gibt auch Nest-Thermostate und Honeywell-Thermostate.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Vor zwei Jahren oder so, als AWS mal down war,
als AWS Probleme hatte,
wo die Leute ihre Heizung nicht richtig einschalten konnten,
da habe ich mir auch gedacht, lul, Alter,
warum macht man sowas über einen Cloud-Service?
...because they're easy to use,
but for me the Ecobee-Thermostat is the best one.
Over here we have a breadbox
and you can probably guess what's inside.
It's what keeps our kids alive.
They're iPads.
Yeah, our kids need these
to live every single day.
And we needed a good spot to store their iPads
and charge them.
So Ali had the idea
to buy this breadbox.
It's really inexpensive off Amazon.
And I just drilled a hole in the box.
...
wo die leute gerade im haus sind da musste aber dein handy dabei haben und so was
das habe ich mir auch mal überlegt das funktioniert bei mir aber nur zum teil
weil ich mein handy oftmals halt nicht mitnehmen also ich nehme mein handy also
ich nehme mein handy eigentlich nie mit außer ich verlasse das haus oder ich gehe aufs klo
weil auf dem klo brauche ich irgendwas wo ich lesen kann aber ansonsten liegt das eigentlich
immer hier neben mir auf dem schreibtisch wenn ich runter in die küche gehen wir was zu trinken
holen nämlich das handy nicht mit wofür brauchen die die kids und die tablets der wahrscheinlich
um microtransactions geld auszugeben das weiß ich was kinders also an tablets eben machen
das motion lights which right here and it's not smart
ja
keine smarte abstellkammer wird champ
die habe ich auch die habe ich nicht ich habe ich habe kein unified 6
was kosten die dinge eigentlich
mittlerweile
ich habe drei ich habe drei nicht wifi6
wobei ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher und leute ich원 will mal kurz auf mein
handy hat bei meine handy gucken was ich was ich für welche habt 46 vielleicht
es vielleicht in die nämlich auch schon wifi 6
am gestrigenen musik farm achievements die kürze kommt hätten
amazon mit amazon history
heute ich habe auch wieder also komisch das ding auf meinem iphone einmal am tag
green turkey
kriege ich jetzt neulich series success ist suggestions suggestions also sie die
empfehlung und einmal am tag sagt mir siri suggestion amazon orders die
empfiehlt mir quasi einmal am tag in meiner amazon orders zu gucken aber ich
habe überhaupt nichts geordert siri ist ziemlich low iq gerade ich weiß gar
nicht warum ich den mist überhaupt an hab auf dem iphone unify nano hd dass
der hat kein wifi 6 der nano hd unify light den habe ich das auch kein wifi 6
ne muss ich muss ich demnächst upgrade unify 6 mal ganz davon abgesehen es ist
ja nicht kein vorteil für mich so wirklich ne also ich meine warum sollte
ich upgrade meine drei access points jetzt auf wifi 6 access points weil
alles funktioniert
wozu ist ja nicht so als werde ich jetzt irgendwie hilfe mein wlan ist
morgen kaputt wenn ich nicht upgrade was ist der vorteil jetzt mal etwa
vielleicht vielleicht hat er einer von euch plan unify 6 versus nano hd so
genau was ist da der vorteil von der user gut 300 mbit über wifi ist jetzt
nicht so als wäre es wie wenig weil du keine wifi 6 endgerät hat ich habe ein
iphone 11
kann das
iphone 11 wifi 6 oder nicht doch anscheinend anscheinend man kann das
aber doch auch bestimmt mischen oder also ich könnte doch ich könnte doch im
keller den alten ac light lassen und den nano hd austauschen durch den wifi 6
also ich muss doch bestimmt nicht alles austauschen wozu oder einen keller für
die drei geräte die da stehen reicht der reiche der normale ac light ja easy aus
hier, should I replace
Hey everybody, today we're taking a look
at the brand new
Okay, das gucke ich mir nachher an, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht zusammen an
rüber
excellent, excellent
So, weiter geht's
Video, wo sind wir schon stehen geblieben?
Hier, keine smarte Abstellkammer
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich
das ist eine gute Frage, sag ich jetzt kurz mal so
Wie funktioniert das eigentlich mit deinem China-WLAN?
Braucht man dann bessere Access-Points
mit mehr Antennen dafür? Nein, braucht man nicht
Du kannst mehrere
SSIDs broadcasten
Ich glaube bei Unify sind es
vier pro Access-Point
Du kannst mit einem Access-Point mehrere SSID
broadcasten
und du brauchst halt einen Access-Point
der WLAN
Einstellung hat
also der WLAN-Unterstützung hat
was eigentlich so gut wie alle etwas
besseren sind und natürlich halt auch
dementsprechend einen Switch auf der anderen Seite
der das kann
Ja, mehrere Antennen braucht er nicht
Das ist eine 2,4 GHz Antenne
oder eine 5 GHz Antenne
da kannst du mehrere SSIDs drüber machen
das ist kein Problem
Dern, die sich dann eigentlich
und schaltet das WiFi 6 der Autobahn
Nee, ich glaube nicht
Ich bin kein großer
WiFi-Kenner, aber das glaube ich nicht
Also ich hab's bei mir so eingestellt
dass Default-WLAN
halt das normale WLAN
benutzt das Default-WLAN
und das China-Chinesen-Geräte-WLAN
hat ein eigenes
Ah, guck mal, Katzenklappe
Ah nee, eine Hundeklappe
Oh, Big-Brain-Idee
Five-Hat-Time
Das ist schlau
Das ist richtig schlau
weil
ich hab mir auch schon mal überlegt
für die Katzenklappe unten
Chico benutzt ja die Katzenklappe nicht
aber ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich die im Sommer
vielleicht, aber egal, gucken wir mal
ich wollte es nämlich im Sommer so machen
dass Chico raus auf die Terrasse kann
nicht komplett in den Hof
und auch nicht irgendwie über die Mauer oder so
aber rauf auf die Terrasse
und ich hab mir schon Gedanken gemacht
wie könnte ich mitbekommen, ob die Katze draußen ist
oder drinnen ist
Meine erste Idee war, ich mach an die Klappe
ein
Fenstersensor
der das erkennt, aber das kann man nicht richtig anbringen
weil die Klappe
die fällt ja hier rein
du kannst wirklich schlecht
einen Sensor anbringen
du könntest höchstens einen Sensor hier oben anbringen
wenn es kurz auf ist
also das ist nicht so zuverlässig
aber das finde ich ist eine super Idee
das muss ich mir aufschreiben
Motion Sensor in die Katzenklappe
sehr gute Idee
richtig clever
und das Gute ist, wir haben sogar einen Stromanschluss direkt daneben
vielleicht kann ich sogar
den Kram an USB anschließen
so ein dünnes USB Kabel nehmen
und irgendwie, mal gucken
mal gucken
das ist gut, das ist gut, das ist eine wirklich schlaue Idee
das gefällt mir
das gefällt mir, das ist eine gute Idee
meine Katze ist gechippt, aber dann bräuchtest du halt irgendwas, was das liest
da musst du dann davor sein und so
weiß ich nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert
kennst du da irgendwelche guten Reader für
ja RFID Reader sind winkelabhängig
und müssen halt relativ nahe sein
je nachdem wie die da durchläuft
ne unbefugte Katzen draußen bleiben geht nicht
denn die unbefugte Katzen kommen ja gar nicht rein
wie gesagt die Terrasse ist ja abgeschlossen
also nicht abgeschlossen, also die ist geschlossen
also du kommst ja von der Terrasse nicht von außen rein und die Katzen nicht raus
da würde ich Chico schocken mit
Laundry Room, ist das Wäsche?
das ist Wäsche, glaube ich, ne?
ok, Leute, Real Talk
ich glaube
das ist eines der sinnlosen Gadgets, wo du Geld für ausgeben kannst
einen smarten Geschirrspüler oder einen smarten Wäschetrockner oder sowas
weil
festzustellen, wann der fertig getrocknet hat, ist glaube ich der eines der einfachsten
kurz die Musiklautstärke checken
eines der einfachsten Dinger überhaupt
man kann einfach eine Steckdose dran machen, die guckt, wie viel Strom das Ding verbraucht
und wenn das Ding, sagen wir mal, über 5 Minuten lang
unter einem gewissen Wert ist
dann weißt du, es ist fertig
und wenn du richtig advanced sein willst, kannst du da auch noch einen Rüttelsensor dran machen
das dürfte wahrscheinlich alles besser und deutlich billiger funktionieren
als irgendwelche smarten Wäschetrockner
also vor allem billiger
Brianetics, danke schon für den Sub
eigentlich eine gute Stelle, ganz ehrlich, im Wäscheraum, warum nicht?
wenn da Platz ist, meine Beluftfeuchtigkeit, je nachdem wie hoch sie da ist, könnte man sich vielleicht nur streiten
aber das macht meistens nichts
es ist eigentlich ein guter Platz, es liegt wahrscheinlich relativ zentral
es wird kaum benutzt und wenn, ist da eh Krach drin
eigentlich ist es, wenn da Platz ist, ist es eigentlich ein super Ort
als Mini-Rack-Serverraum
dort, wo die Wäsche ist, warum nicht?
ja, da bin ich kein großer Fan von
Laurin, danke für den Sub
der Name von dem Staubsauger, Alter
Dyson Cyclone V10 Animal Plus
alles klar
aber wahrscheinlich Animal, weil der für Haustierhaare ist, hä?
16.5 Bits, Gachi Bus
ja, das hatte ich auch so
das hatte ich auch so
aber ich hab's letzten Sonntag ja schon erzählt
ähm, ich verwende aktuell meinen Staubsauger-Roboter nicht mehr
sondern ich fahr da alle paar Wochen mal 10 Minuten lang mit dem richtigen Staubsauger durch
und gut ist
nein, das mag ich nicht
ich seh's nicht ein, ich will keinen Roboter haben mit Kameras vorne
der vor allem dann auch noch über die China-Chinesen-Cloud geht
ich mag die Dream Machines auch nicht
ich kann dir gar nicht so genau sagen, warum
aber jedes Mal, wenn ich mir das durchgelesen hab
äh, gerade auch das Webinterface, wo du dann nicht so sehr ins Detail kannst
hat mich nicht so überzeugt, ja
Dyson ist echt Müll, ist das so?
weiß ich nicht, kann ich nix zu sagen
makes no sense Dota 16 Monate
Dankeschön für den Sub
huge Subscription hier
ich verwende ihn nicht mehr, weil's schneller ist
10 Minuten lang einfach mal mit dem richtigen Staubsauger durchzuführen
also, wenn das passiert, bin ich gar nicht verrückt
ich bin nur beeindruckt, wie viel meine Kinder
gibt es, gibt es, äh, äh, OpenWrt oder sowas vor Dream Machine?
wobei, es heißt, es heißt doch nicht mehr OpenWrt, es heißt jetzt Lede, oder?
Lede?
nee, wie heißt denn der Kram jetzt, es heißt doch Lede, Lede heißt es doch jetzt, oder?
Open, OpenWrt Dream Machine
gibt's das?
das wär, wär schon besser zu benutzen, ja
Kids can destroy in one day
here in the hallway we have a few brilliant light switches
that we're using the motion sensors to turn on the lights
we also use the brilliant light switches to quickly
wisst ihr, das, sowas hab ich mir auch mal überlegt
aber du hast immer nen kleines Delay
guck mal, stellt euch mal vor, der läuft schneller
stellt euch mal vor, der läuft schneller, guck mal, der ist jetzt schon relativ langsam gelaufen
das Licht geht an, da ist er schon quasi 2 Drittel durch den Raum durch
wenn du schnell läufst, bist du durch den Raum durch und hinter dir geht das Licht an
we also use the brilliant light switches to quickly make changes to our smart home as well
there's some Z-Wave and ZigBee extenders right here
because this is kind of the middle of our house
and the ZigBee extender is just a smart outlet that's not plugged into anything
that works really well
ja, das ist normal, das ist kein, das ist kein ZigBee extender, so ist ZigBee gedacht
ZigBee ist als Mesh gedacht
genauso wie Z-Wave
alle Geräte, die du in die Steckdose steckst
oder alle Geräte, die permanent am Strom sind
fungieren quasi als, nennen wir es Extender, Repeater, wie auch immer
also sind, werden quasi zu einem festen Mesh-Node, der die Sachen weiterleitet
das ist der Sinn von ZigBee und Z-Wave
deswegen ist die Abdeckung und die Reichweite davon auch so gut
and the range of the ZigBee signal
the front window right here is smart
it's using just this little smart wand
and it's automated to open up in the morning
was ist daran smart?
and close right before sunset
ich mein, er dreht da dran
oder dreht sich das automatisch?
hat, dreht er da jetzt dran oder ist das ein Motor, der automatisch dreht?
it's automated to open up in the morning
also wenn das ein Motor ist, dann ist das natürlich Pfeifendlösung
aber gut, da muss ja ein Anschluss, da muss eine Steckdose in der Nähe sein
das ist auch sowas, wo ich mich noch nicht dazu durchgerungen hab
ich hab mir mal einmal testweise...
so einen automatischen Rollladenwickler gekauft
weil ich hab ja noch mindestens 4 Räume mit so einem klassischen Holzrollladen
richtig fetten schweren Ding
hab ich mich aber noch nicht dazu durchgerungen das zu machen
weil ganz im Ernst
morgens schnell hochziehen
und meistens lass ich den sogar abends auf
weil ich zu faul bin
aber mal morgens irgendwie, wenn es doch zu ist, mal schnell hochziehen
ist kein Ding, also
ich finde, man muss es an den Stellen machen, wo es Sinn macht
und an den Stellen, wo es einen nervt
gerade dort ist Heimautomatisierung sinnvoll
wenn es einem Arbeit abnimmt, die nervt
und dementsprechend ist es auch immer was individuelles
ich seh total viele Leute, die fangen an
mit LEDs, RGB-LEDs durchs ganze Haus
90% der Stellen braucht man überhaupt keine RGB-LEDs
man braucht vielleicht was dimmbares, aber keine RGB-LEDs
und dann denken sie sich, ja was kann ich denn jetzt machen
also das ist, finde ich, der falsche Ansatz
man muss sich überlegen, was einen stört
und das dann umbauen und nicht umgedreht
nur weil man coole YouTube-Videos gesehen hat, die alle RGBs haben
oder irgendwelche Sensoren oder sonst was, die auch einbauen
wenn das eigentlich nichts ist, was einen stört
wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
also man muss direkt den Mehrwert dafür schaffen
und gerade wenn man nicht alleine ist
ist es besonders wichtig, dass halt auch die anderen Personen, die das bauen
das auch benutzen müssen
das erstens gut benutzen können
und zweitens den Mehrwert davon sehen
deswegen war das erste, was ich damals auch gemacht hab, ist
eine, tatsächlich eine RGB-LED
die per Farbe anzeigt, wenn ich morgens aus dem Schlafzimmer komme
anzeigt, ob mein Zug Verspätung hat oder nicht
ich hab die Tür aufgemacht, hab gleich gesehen, oh nee, rot
das hat, war tatsächlich Mehrwert, das hat tatsächlich was gebracht
hab ich aber übrigens mittlerweile nicht mehr
was da...
der ist in Rauch aufgegangen
oh, das ist schlecht
gerade, weil man die Dinger ja auch einstellt auf automatisch
ne, man stellt ja so einen Rollladenwickler ein
keine Ahnung, geh morgens um 8 automatisch auf
geh bei Sonnenuntergang automatisch zu und sowas
das heißt, die Dinger rollladenwickeln, auch wenn man nicht daheim ist
wenn das anfängt zu rauchen und anfängt zu brennen und man ist nicht da
dann ist man ganz schön... das ist gefährlich, ja
willst du verraten, was das für einer war?
ich hab ein von... ich hab ein Duo... nee, wie heißt dieses Ding?
oh, ich hab vergessen... Duo... Duo Gurt?
oder sowas?
Moment, Moment
Rollladenwickler Duo... Duo Fern...
ich glaub, davon hab ich mir mal einen geholt, als der im Angebot war
für irgendwie keine Ahnung, 60 Euro oder sowas
180, die sind eigentlich verstört
und hab mir den offiziellen USB-Stick von denen geholt
weil ich das damit automatisiert habe, ja?
weil ich das damit automatisieren wollte, hab ich aber nie gemacht
Trinity, danke für den Sub
die Oberfläche von der Tree Machine, sagt der Chat, wird mit jedem Update schlechter
äh, kann ich... zur Tree Machine kann ich nichts sagen, aber ich muss...
ich muss sagen, ich bin mit dem Unify-Update auch nicht so wirklich glücklich
das Neue sieht zwar schöner aus, aber die haben einige Funktionen gestrichen
ich hab instant wieder zurück auf die alte... auf die alte Oberfläche für Unify geschaltet
vor allem finde ich da wenigstens was
Rademacher hab ich auch, ja?
genau, die hab ich auch
die hab ich auch gehabt, ja, zum Testen
oh, wenn der anfängt zu rauchen, ist aber echt schlecht
das war aktuell, das hat die deutsche Bahn-Integration von Home Assistant verwendet
DNS-Challenge failed, was ist los, Chat?
warum failed eure DNS-Challenge?
DNS-Challenge failed, failed to find zone
ähm, wenn du DNS-Challenge machst, muss der Traffic
API-Zugang zum DNS-Server haben, ne?
der muss da einen geheimen Key hinterlegen
hat dein Traffic API-Access auf deinen DNS?
und ist dein DNS auch beim Domain-Registrar eingestellt?
sonst funktioniert das nicht
aber du musst keine DNS-Challenge machen
wenn das Ding eh im Internet steht, kannst du auch normale HTTP-Challenge machen
dann brauchst du nur eine Eintragung, gut ist
Zomfy haben wir auch
die... Alter, was geht mit der Musik?
aber das ist grad viel zu episch hier, Geschichte hier
ähm...
Zomfy haben wir auch bei den anderen Fenstern
die nicht mehr diese oldschool fetten Rollern, Holzrollläden haben
die haben auch schon einen Motor, das ist relativ easy
und die kann ich auch fernsteuern, noch richtig oldschool über Funk
also RF 433 oder was das ist
das funktioniert, die kann ich steuern
Bad oben, Bad unten, Küche unten, kein Ding
ne und das ist doof, ich hab mir damals noch einen gekauft, ich hab den noch hier
Pain in the ass, Sketchybuzz
danke für den Sub, Leute
Luxius, Slimey und Flofus
tja, dann würde ich mal die DNS-Management-Konsole aus dem Webinterface aufmachen
während dein Traffic läuft und gucken
ob dein Traffic dort Sachen anlegt
da müssten ja dann TXT-Records auftauchen
wenn da keine TXT-Records auftauchen
dann scheint es nicht zu funktionieren
ok, die Web-Oberfläche sagt
Unterschied zwischen Para-Virtualisierung M und was und VMM
was, was ist VMM, was ist VMM, Leute
ich bin, ich bin low IQ, was, was ist VMM
Virtual Machine Monitor, hä?
ich hab keine Ahnung
eine Frage, ich will, wenn mein PC ausgeschaltet ist, automatisch meine Steckdosen vom PC ausschalten
nachdem dreimal der Ping gefällt
es gibt, ja easy
kannst du Home Assistant easy machen, easy
überhaupt gar kein Problem
kannst du machen
ist sogar eine richtig gute Idee, finde ich
kannst du easy machen
Home Assistant, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es da einen ICMP oder sowas gibt
ja, gibt es
ICMP-Sensor kannst du machen
ICMP-Sensor und dann sagst du hier
wenn der, wenn der auf off geht
oder wenn der auf failed geht
dann schaltest du nach 5 Minuten aus
ich würde das gar nicht nach 3 failed Pings machen
ich würde das, ich würde sagen, wenn der Sensor für 10 Minuten auf aus steht
dann macht die Steckdose aus
das ist mit Home Assistant easy, das ist 3 Zeilen Automatisierung
ja
ok, was, ah, wir müssen uns die Smart Home Tour ja noch fertig angucken
...and close right before sunset
there is some smart outlets right here that control all of our porch lights
and those will turn on at sunset
ich finde diese Kokona-Switch so reingeschnitten in die Wand immer so geil
...and turn off when we're going to bed
and then if it's really late at night and someone comes up to our front door
there is an automation that will turn on those front porch lights from the doorbell
so that way we can see who's there
and maybe even scare off anybody if they weren't supposed to be there
alright, now let's go check out the garage
we have a ring contact sensor
äh, Moment, muss ich auch kurz was zu sagen, hier geht ja wieder Schlager auf Schlager im Chat
noch so ein Ding, Home Assistant auf dem Pi direkt drauf oder in Docker-Container
irgendwas war doch kacke
ähm, ja, du kannst, ähm, das nicht mehr richtig machen mit selbst Docker-Container
wenn du Home Assistant verwenden willst
das ist keine supportete, also diese Home Assistant Super Vice ist keine richtige supportete Konfiguration mehr
da spackt das Ding rum
ähm, die beste Variante, wenn du es auf dem Raspberry Pi machen willst, ist tatsächlich
das direkt auf dem Raspberry Pi installieren
aber, aber
mach's mit SSD
nehm den USB zu SSD und papp dir nur, papp dir mit, mit paar Tesa Power-Strips oder mit ähm
Velcro-Dinger oder was auch immer
papp dir eine SSD unter den Raspberry Pi
also du hast ja ein Raspberry Pi-Gehäuse, papp dir eine SSD drunter
und mach das darauf, weil Home Assistant ist abfuck langsam über MicroSD
also wenn du, wenn du es mit dem Raspberry Pi machen willst, dann würde ich einen kompletten Raspberry Pi für Home Assistant opfern
ja, das würde ich machen
ich hab's bei mir anders
ich hab ne 4M auf meiner Low Power Intel x86 Hardware, ne 4M mit Home Assistant
die tut auch wunderbar
das wird dauern
wenn überhaupt
das ist auch ne gute Idee, ja man kann den BIOS einstellen, sobald der Strom wieder da ist, geht er an
da kannst du auch wieder drüber, ja
der Pi, jaja klar
aber nur über MicroSD ist langsam
ein Raspberry Pi 3 hat auch genug Leistung
du brauchst auch keine 8 GB RAM, vier reichen
den Friedhof Sensor, der ist nicht im Einsatz
den hab ich ja nie fertig gebaut, aber ist immer noch in Planung
was nimmst du als Hypervisor?
ich hab ganz normales KVM
KVM Wirt Manager, die easyste Sache überhaupt
die man unter Linux machen kann
Piste angelegt, Home Assistant drauf, fertig
ja, wir haben ne, ich hab mit LoRa, über LoRa waren mal nen Sensor programmiert mit Bodenfeuchtigkeit, also
das war nen ESP32 mit Batterie und Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor und nem LoRa Sender
und ich wollte das auf den Friedhof bringen, der ist, der ist irgendwie 1,5 km weg von hier
auf den Friedhof bringen, wo das Grab von Opa und Oma ist
und wollte das quasi dort, ähm
den, den Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor dort reinstecken
dass der mir sagt, dass der mir heimschickt über LoRa
das hat übrigens auch funktioniert, das hab ich ausprobiert, also von der Entfernung her ging das
aber nur im allerniedrigsten Übertragungsmodus
dass der mir heimschickt
wie feucht oder trocken das Grab im Sommer ist, dass ich weiß wann ich gießen gehen muss
Smart Grave
ne
weiß ich nicht
kann ich dir nix empfehlen
so, wir gucken jetzt aber echt mal das Video fertig
es wird immer langsam Zeit, äh, wir haben wieder 3 Videos heute geschafft
Garage
ist es Garage oder Garage?
ich kann mir das wahrscheinlich da, je nachdem wo man herkommt
ihr seht, es ist wirklich hell hier
und es ist ein schönes weißes Licht
und es leuchtet die ganze Garage auf und macht es so zu fühlen, wie in einem Shop
wo man hier hängen und arbeiten möchte
und es ist automatisiert mit einem klaren Outlet
es ist einfach direkt da oben im Garten
also, wenn jede der Garage-Türen öffnet werden all diese Lichter auf
es ist wirklich, wirklich schön
und hier
diese Garage ist immer noch
eine Arbeit im Prozess
aber wir haben einen Echo-Dock
natürlich, was sonst?
warum hat der überall irgendwelche Echos rumstehen?
FBI open up
... und ein Weißkamm B3, um Sachen aufzuhalten
wir haben auch 3 Tesla-Powerwalls hier
und diese Sachen sind großartig, weil sie unsere ganze Haus-
sogar unsere 2 AC-Units, wenn der Grid runter ist
und wir benutzen diese mit unseren Tesla-Solar-Paneln auf unserem Ruf
und wir haben ein ganzes Video gemacht über die Tesla-Powerwalls
gut
der ist ja auch irgendwo mitten in der Wüste oder so
ich weiß nicht mehr, wo er wohnt, aber das war wirklich was mit irgendwie
gefühlt jeden Tag
30 Stunden Sonne, so
was schwierig wird für jeden Tag
... Panels that you can go check out after this video
so in the master bedroom we have a contact sensor up on the door
that we have also on the other bedroom doors as well
to run automation so that if you have to go get a drink in the middle of the night
it will turn on these hallway lights
boah, das wäre mir viel zu krass, ne?
wenn ich jetzt ... stell mir grad vor
ich geh nachts mal aufs Klo
und das erste was ist, ist so ein LED-Licht, was mir von der Decke ins Gesicht scheint
ja, super
and we also have a motion sensor in here
as you can see by the light just turning on
it's on the bookshelf as well, similar to that family room
all the lights in here are neutron switches
as well as the shades, they're smart shades
that can wake me up in the morning, which ...
ich hab grad gedacht, der hat da RGB drumherum
er hat LEDs drumherum, aber das ist Licht von außen
there are smart shades that can wake me up in the morning
which my wife's not a huge fan of
what's cool is these lights that are controlled by Lutron
as well as these Lutron shades
have these little Pico remotes
and you can put those somewhere and easily control them anywhere in the room
so we have some in my wife's nightstand
and that way she can control the lights and the shades very easily
we also have a mounted TV
that's kind of far away from our bed
so we're using the Echo Dots on our nightstand
wie viel Fernseher hat der jetzt?
drei, vier, fünf?
... as speakers for the TV
that way we don't have to blast sound across the room
der hat bestimmt im Klo auch einen
... and wake up everyone in the house at night
and before you're like, whoa, you have Echo Dots listening to you in your bedroom
don't worry, we also have a Google Home Display also listening as well
im Leben nicht
sowas
nicht nur im Bedroom
überhaupt nicht
oh, das ist eine gute Idee
wenn es sowas ist, was per Druck feststellt, ob jemand drinnen liegt im Bett
das ist sinnvoll
das finde ich tatsächlich ganz cool, sowas kann man machen
ich hab's aktuell mit einem NFC-Tag
einfach Handy dranhalten und easy, wir gehen ins Bett
aber man kann's auch komplett automatisch machen
dass das alles ausschaltet, was noch an ist, wenn man, keine Ahnung, eine Viertelstunde im Bett liegt und es nach 22 Uhr ist
das finde ich ist eine gute Idee
... my mattress to keep track of my sleep as well as run automations if I'm getting into bed or getting out of bed
was kostet denn das?
wie hieß das Ding, with things?
... sleep?
... mattress? nee, sleep? sleep?
... a sleep analyzer?
... ich will kein sleep analyzer, ich will einfach irgendwas, was mir sagt, wenn man im Bett liegt
... ähm ...
... sleep analyzer, home assistant
... gibt's da eine integration?
... is anyone still working on?
... iiih, über die Cloud!
... äh ...
... ja, das mit den Load-Cells unter die Füße hab ich mir auch gedacht
auch welche. Das ist
eher was für draufstellen und dann wieder runter machen.
Loudsales mögen eigentlich in der Regel dauerhafte
Belastung nicht so.
Aber okay.
Das ist natürlich scheiße, wie das
hier gemacht ist. Ne, das kannst du knicken.
Solange es da keine
ordentliche Homelessness-Integration gibt, kaufe
ich mir sowas nicht.
Beste.
Siehste?
Dadurch, dass es
vom Hersteller integriert ist,
wenn der Hersteller keinen Bock mehr hat, YouTube
zu supporten, geht es nicht mehr richtig.
Beziehungsweise wenn das Android outdated oder sonst was.
Das ist immer die Gefahr dahinter,
wenn es solche kompletten
äh
Build-In-Systeme sind.
Ich meine, warum nicht einfach
ein Fahrrad dahinstellen und
sich ein Tablet vorne dran mounten selbst?
Dann ist man nicht
daran gebunden.
Oder einen Fernseher
hier vorne hinstellen oder so.
Alter!
Das ist ja auch Maximum-Overkill
in der Steckdose, oder?
Also, vielmehr geht er
aber nicht mehr rein. Das ist ja
wirklich komplett, komplett dicht,
Alter.
Ein Echo-Dot, das wir hören, wenn wir
getting ready or showering.
This motion sensor is awesome because
it's like a 6-in-1 sensor.
It has humidity, light and a bunch of other
things. And it can plug in for power, so you
don't have to worry about that.
Genau den gleichen habe ich, das ist ein Z-Wave.
Das ist ein Z-Wave. Z-Wave motion und
Temperatursensor.
Genau das Ding steht bei mir hinter mir im
Surferraum und checkt, wenn ich die Tür aufmache.
Und sich da drin was bewegt.
Also turns off the lights if it does not
detect motion. You might be wondering,
what if someone is showering?
Well, there's an override
to stop that from happening. So,
if the shower light or the shower exhaust
fan is on, then the motion detection
will not turn on the lights.
I'm using a bunch of smart dimmer switches
for this bathroom, and these ones
are from Kasa, and throughout the house
I'm mainly using Lutron, but
I wanted to see if these inexpensive
Kasa Wi-Fi dimmer switches would
work well, and surprisingly
they do. So, I recommend
these things. Alright, before we head into
the office, there's a smart light out here,
that will turn red whenever I'm
in a meeting. And it does...
Was für Sensoren? Nehmen wir mal die
Schalter? Keine... Irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Ami-Dinger, die man in die Wand sägt. Keine Ahnung.
...automatically using my Google Calendar.
Anytime it sees the word
meeting in a calendar event,
that way my family knows that I'm
probably on a call with the light... Gute Idee.
Gut, das ist eine gute Idee. Das, das ist eine gute
Idee, wenn man Angst hat, dass jemand reinkommt, während
man mietet. Das ist eine gute Idee, find ich nice.
...it's red. In the office
we have a lot of smart lights...
Oh, teuer. Die Dinger sind so
unverhältnismäßig
teuer, Nanoleafs.
...that look amazing, as well as
some Ikea Smart Shades,
that are connected to the SmartThings
Hub. And we have a few other Hubs in here...
Warum hat der so viel... Warum hat der...
Ich meine, der benutzt doch Home Assistant. Warum
hat der 30 Milliarden verschiedene
Hubs und Apps und Geräte?
...like the HomePod Mini,
that uses thread, as well
as a bond bridge... BTF!
...that bond bridge is pretty cool, because
it turns all of our RF
fans in our house smart.
...I highly recommend... Der will's aber wissen,
...the fans already use a remote to make them smart.
...and then we also have a broadlink
button that can control
everything, so... So'n Ding hab ich auch,
aber kein Broadlink-Button, sondern ein
Aquara-Button über Zigbee.
Ein, äh, Six-Way-Switch.
Der unterscheiden
zwischen Single-Press, Doppel-Press,
Long-Press und Triple-Press.
Also ich könnte theoretisch
sechs mal vier Funktionen da drauf
legen. Theoretisch
sogar mehrere Doppel-Press. Ich könnte da...
kann ich gar nicht ausrechnen, wie viele Funktionen...
Ich versteh... Was macht der mit den...
Was macht der mit diesen ganzen Echo und Nest
und Dings-Hub-Dingern? Also...
Warum hat er so viele... Warum hat er so
viele, äh, Amazon...
Redet er dann permanent damit? Sagt er dann,
wenn er beim... Wenn er am Rechner sitzt, irgendwie,
äh, keine Ahnung, äh,
äh...
Was sagt man denn da? Äh,
Hallo Echo, oder Hey Alexa,
sagt man dann wahrscheinlich, äh,
macht das Radio an, oder... Oder was? Oder...
Warum braucht man das in jedem Raum?
Ich meine, jeder wie er mag, aber...
Noch einer!
...
Aha!
Da müsste mal der Logpicking-Läuer
dran!
...
Die hab ich auch!
Die hab ich... LIFX hab ich auch ein paar Dinge. Also alle RGB-Lampen,
die ich habe, sind LIFX.
Die sind zwar nicht billig, aber ich finde, die sind ganz gut.
Und sie sind WiFi.
Sie brauchen keine extra Special Hubs und sowas.
Hat er das alles gesponsert bekommen?
Ey, würd mich nicht wundern.
Es ist mega zusammengewürfelt, ne?
Der hat alles von allem in irgendwie ne Kombination.
...
so in der Katzenklappe, finde ich, ist eine richtig geile
Idee.
Ja, ich auch. Ich würde auch
keine Voice Assistance nehmen.
She baited.
Please, kein Kindergeschrei jetzt.
Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Das meiste ist aber nicht wirklich
smart.
Ich finde, es ist wichtig, dass man die Sachen smart macht,
an den Stellen, wo es nervt.
Zum Beispiel, auch eine Sache, die
für mich viel mehr Wert hat, ist
den NFC-Tag, den ich im Bad
habe. Ich habe einen NFC-Tag
am Wäsche...
Es war mal ein Wäschekorb, mittlerweile ist es ein Klopapierkorb.
Der Korb, wo ich die
Klopapierrollen im Bad drin liegen habe, der hat einen
NFC-Tag. Da scanne ich mein Handy
und dann geht der Heizlüfter an, dass es schnell warm wird.
Wird da.
Und ich habe sogar ein Video davon,
irgendwo. NFC.
Ja, Max, halt die Klappe.
Guck da. Heizlüfter.
Ich glaube,
ich muss den Sound anmachen, sonst hört man das nicht.
Die Waage geht
übrigens auch per Bluetooth direkt in Home Assistant.
Bei mir rein.
Okay, Max, doch nicht. Ich kann mich da nicht
selbst anhören. Also, da ist Heizlüfter.
Und jetzt
zeige ich euch gleich den NFC-Tag, wo das Handy
gescannt wird.
Ein bisschen sinnlos rumgehen.
Übrigens, Twitter-Videos sind qualitativ so schlecht
und Paintschamp. Da.
Wäschekorb, oder besser gesagt, Klopapierkorb.
Von welcher Marke sind die
Server in deiner Firma?
Das meiste ist Dell.
Wir haben aber auch ein paar
P und noch ein bisschen IBM.
Aber das meiste ist Dell.
Guck da, das ist ein NFC-Tag.
Kostet 2 Cent, so ein NFC-Tag.
Gibt's für
2 Euro ein 20er-Pack bei Amazon.
Das ist billig.
Guck, jetzt.
Drangehalten und
zack geht der Heizer an.
Und nochmal drangehalten, zack.
Heizer geht aus.
Und Heizer wieder an.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das 10 Mal mache in dem Video.
Das ist
praktisch, weil ich hab immer vergessen,
wenn ich, was weiß ich, wenn's richtig
drückt,
hab ich immer keinen Bock,
da hinten auf den Knopf zu drücken, dass der Heizer angeht.
Dann flitze ich durch aufs Klo
und dann sitze ich auf dem Klo und denke mir,
ah, bisschen kühl hier. Und dann halte ich das Handy
an den NFC-Tag dran und der Heizer geht an.
Sehr praktisch. Sehr praktisch.
Und danach kann ich mich
nebendran gleich auf die Bluetooth-Waage stellen
und
Pippo-Fett-Gewicht in Home Assistant übertragen,
dass ich einen schönen Graph habe,
wie es langsam runtergeht.
Oder auch nicht.
First-World-Problems. Ja, wir sind ja zum Glück First-World.
Da kann man auch First-World-Problems haben.
Ach ja, genau. Hier ist die, hier ist die, äh,
WLAN-Steckdose. Die haben wir übrigens zusammen
im Stream geflasht, glaube.
Ne, mein Klo hat keine Home Assistant-Integration.
Das ist zu alt.
Gut, ich glaub, mehr kommt in dem Video nicht mehr.
Da kann man auch dran ein- und ausschalten.
Ja, das war zum Beispiel was,
das hat für mich echt Mehrwert gebracht.
Ist deinem Klo auch... Nein, Quatsch.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
How to land a 100K-Job
pro Jahr.
Tech-Job, Ten-Strand, Fireship.
Fireship macht immer gute Videos.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Strong Mindset.
Location.
Master the Twitter Game. Aha.
LinkedIn, Igitt.
Übrigens, mein LinkedIn-Account ist immer noch da.
Der wird nicht,
ich weiß nicht, warum die den nicht löschen.
Ich hab noch nicht mal mehr das Passwort dafür
mittlerweile.
Aber der ist immer noch da.
Benutzt du einen extra Browser,
wo du angemeldet bist?
Jaja, ich hab nen extra Windows-Account,
wo ich angemeldet bin.
Was kann man uns sonst noch angucken?
Irgendjemand hat gesagt, wir sollen uns das Video vom Lost
angucken. Weiß nicht, ob ich mir jetzt noch
das Elend von Battlefield 2042
geben will.
Was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Playstation-Emulation, Lego
Gear Train. Das gucken wir jetzt.
Die find ich immer geil, die Lego-Videos.
Das NFT-Video. Stimmt.
Ich hatte irgendwo ein Video.
What the hell are NFTs?
Ich finde, er hat das echt gut erklärt.
Aber es sind 22 Minuten. 22 Minuten NFT.
Can't wait.
Ich muss mir jetzt erstmal Lego-Stells angucken.
Sorry, Klemmbaustein-Stells.
Klemmbausteine, muss man ja sagen.
Man weiß ja nicht, ob es wirklich
Lego ist.
Easy.
Ich mein, irgendwann ist dank Reibung und Widerstand
ja mal Schluss.
Oh, MonkaS.
Oh, oh.
Gleich ist, gleich ist,
gleich ist vorbei.
Ach nee, der hat zwei
Powerstufen, oder wie?
Oh.
Das erzeugt ja noch mehr Reibung jetzt oben.
Es hat wirklich seine Probleme.
Es leiert schon richtig heftig.
Oh. Der Motor,
das tut ja richtig weh, da zuzugucken.
Oh.
Volle Bulle.
Okay, jetzt ist aber Schluss.
Also, mehr kann dann immer gehen.
Aha, kleinere Übersetzung.
Äh, ist das
kleinere Übersetzung oder größere
Übersetzung? Wie sagt man da eigentlich jetzt richtig zu?
Also, es hat auf jeden Fall mehr Power.
Dafür dreht's
langsamer.
Okay, gleich ist Schluss. Allein schon
von der Videolänge.
Coggers, ja.
111.
111 Coggers.
Doch, er hat am Motor ein kleineres angeschlossen.
Das dreht sich dreimal rum,
dann sind die Batterien alle wahrscheinlich.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. 111
Zahnräder.
Mit Öl schmieren. Das wird wahrscheinlich wirklich
was bringen. Aber da musst du den
Lego-Sachen danach sauber machen.
What the hell
are NFTs? Leute, 22
Minuten Video. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht. Oh ne, das gucken wir uns
heute bestimmt nicht an. Das ist
ein zu kontroverses Thema,
als dass ich mir das heute geben kann.
22 Minuten dauern hier 2 Stunden.
Ja, ihr kennt mich. Ihr kennt mich.
Wenn ich erst mal anfange was zu gucken
und immer was dazu sagen muss, dann dauert das
ewig. Was? Welches Video?
Hat hier mal ein Video gepostet?
Ja, Smart Home Stuff. Ja, die sind
auch so lang.
Ich suche eine gute und billige Steckdose
mit Strommesser, die man mit das Motor flashen kann.
Tja, das Problem ist, ich könnte dir
eine empfehlen, aber die Sache ist, man weiß nicht,
ob es halt heute noch flashbar ist.
Ich hab
mittlerweile für mich so die ultimative Steckdose
gefunden. 2x USB, kann
den Strom messen und kann flashen, kann man flashen,
aber die sind wahrscheinlich nicht mehr flashbar.
Die haben wir hier auch zusammen im Stream geflasht.
Ähm...
Die sind wahrscheinlich... Wollen wir mal gucken,
ob die noch flashbar sind. Ich muss mal kurz in meine
Amazon History gucken, welche das waren.
Ich guck mal kurz.
Guck mal kurz in meine Orders History.
Steckdose.
Ja, die da sind das.
Na super, kein Bild mehr.
Ist nicht mal verfügbar, das Produkt.
Das einzige, was ich bei mir noch
habe, ist die Bestellhistorie.
Und dass das Ding hieß
Smart, aber das ist total
generic, Smart Socket
with 2 USB
Ports. Na super.
Weiß noch jemand?
Die da sind das. Ja.
Die sind das.
Weil im Prinzip ist ja auch alles rebranded.
China-Chinesen Zeug, ne.
Die sind das. Die sind wirklich nice.
Ja, deswegen gibt's die auch
von 30 verschiedenen Herstellern.
Weil das alles nur rebranded ist.
Was Chinesen Zeug ist.
Die sind halt cool, zweimal USB.
Du kannst USB schalten, den Strom schalten.
Das kann dann Strom messen, ist gut.
Die Sache ist halt die.
Flashbar sind die nur, wenn die alte
Firmware haben. Also over the air flashbar.
Nur wenn die alte Firmware haben.
Und wenn man Pech hat,
wenn man Pech hat,
ähm, sind die sogar
nicht mal mehr mit nem ESP32.
Ähm, mit nem ESP2866.
Wenn die nicht mehr mit nem ESP2866
sind und nem ESP32 ist mit Tasmota flashen
eh nix.
Guck mal mal, was hier die Amazon-Dinger sagen.
Störung im Betrieb. Ja, deswegen
verwendet man die ja auch nicht mit der Standard.
Nope.
Kann man nicht sagen. Also es ist wirklich
schwierig. Es gibt kaum noch welche neue, die man
Tasmota flashen kann. Leider.
Julia Convert.
Mal gucken, wann's dann das letzte Update gab.
Ob's da vielleicht irgendwas neues gibt.
Es gibt ja zwei Probleme. Erstens, dass die neue
äh, Firmware
nicht mehr sich einfach
flashen lässt. Und das zweite ist,
dass sie eben gar kein
ESP2866 mehr haben.
Und wenn es ein anderer Chip ist, dann funktioniert
die, funktioniert Tasmota eh nicht.
Und das ist ziemlich
kacke. Hey, wann, wenn
da jetzt Knappheit ist,
heißt das, dass man...
Vielleicht. Vielleicht.
Ich hab auch noch so viel von dem, also nicht von den
Sonoffs, aber von diesen ganzen Dingern hier.
Ich hab mir extra nochmal
nen Fünferpack Steckdosenleisten gekauft,
als ich welche gefunden hab, die man Tasmota flashen kann.
Dass für die nächsten Jahre meine
Steckdosenleisten-Needs
erstmal abgedeckt sind.
Was macht Battlefield mit seinen Updates?
Ja, nix. Ach ja, es gibt
jetzt ein Scoreboard. Hab ich auch gelesen. Leute,
es gibt jetzt ein Scoreboard.
Nach, also nein, wird es geben.
Gibt es noch nicht. Wird es geben. Legacy
Feature. Nachdem die Leute lange genug
rumgemeckert haben. Wieder Willen.
Die Gosund-Dinger sind auch nicht schlecht. Da hab ich
auch ein paar von, ja.
Gesund. Ich bringe jetzt nicht den Corona-Witz
zum 85.000. Mal mit Gesund.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Darf ich, darf ich
offgehen? Chat. Chat ist
erlaubt. Darf ich offgehen?
Darf ich offgehen, wenn wir nachher noch ein bisschen
Programmier-Streams
machen? Wer macht nachher eh keinen
Stream? Ihr kennt mich, Leute.
Aber ich will das
ausprobieren. Ich mach wahrscheinlich tatsächlich
nachher streamen.
Wir programmieren ins Welt
Total Complete. Irgendjemand, dem ich
voll... Was macht mein Manager? Ist mein Manager?
Der hat sich mega...
Übrigens nochmal, Leute. Nice, dass ihr
alle rübergegangen seid beim letzten Raid. Er hat sich
mega gefreut.
Nope.
Ist nicht on. Er hat sich mega gefreut,
dass wir ihn geradet haben. War richtig happy.
Kannst du mal ein Stream-Video
zu deinem Manjaro-Setup machen? Hab ich schon.
Musste mal im Archiv gucken.
Archiv? Wo bloß?
Manjaro.
Da haben wir, glaube ich, angefangen.
Also, guck mal. Wir haben sogar zwei Streams
gemacht. Perfekt einrichten
und from scratch einrichten.
Was auch immer da der Unterschied ist.
Das ist der neuere. Den würde ich mir angucken.
Den würde ich mir angucken.
Vier Stunden!
Wir haben seriously vier Stunden
mein Linux eingerichtet. Alter, was ist denn
da los?
Vier Stunden?
Achso. Ja, da hab ich die... Verwende ich ja gar nicht
die Schriftart.
Aber das ASCII-Quarium ist am Start.
Okay. Ich hab bestimmt
eineinhalb... Wir haben Barbecue Pit Boys am Ende
geguckt. Okay. Der Stream geht legit wahrscheinlich
bloß zweieinhalb Stunden oder so.
Ich find das nice. Ja, tatsächlich.
Ich bin ja so View-Fanboy
immer gewesen. Aber das Welt macht
auch Bock. Schadet, glaube ich, nichts, wenn man da
ein bisschen den Überblick hat.
Über aktuelle
Frontend-Technologies.
Der Rest war Wodafone-Flame.
Philo, danke für den Sub. Auch danke an alle Subs,
die ich heute vielleicht nicht gesehen habe. Ich schau mal
ganz schnell rein noch.
Creator-Dashboard...
Ne, hab alle gesehen.
Fuck, glaube ich. Tainser hab ich
schon gesehen.
Leute, die Pepo fett. Ich geh jetzt restlichen
Nudel-Spaghetti-Bolognese
von gestern futtern.
Wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Macht's gut.
See you.